[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by chime look where we
are houston texas
for the angels taking on the astros you
want superstars you have superstars all
over the baseball field mike trout
shohei ohtani dusty baker's club with
alex bregman and carlos correa correa
leading off for the first time in his
career oh there's albert pujols and i
mean you name it there's a superstar
involved with these two clubs and
we can't wait to see them battle they
are exclusively on youtube tonight
it will be live with matt bash version
calling the action with a whole bunch of
friends and we'll get you going for 30
minutes all about the astros and the
angels scott braun and jim tomy so great
to see you yeah thanks scott it's great
to be back and uh what a game this is
going to be it's going to be
it'll be a fun game to watch because as
you said there's so many great players
yep on both sides here and it's uh it's
always nice to see good baseball this
early in the year i felt like when i was
walking out with you just now there
would be some you know
walk-up music or something like that you
didn't care what you saw they could do
that no no whatever they played they
could play i just
tried to do the job in the batter's box
yeah jim was like you know what i'm just
gonna do a little bit of this yeah it
all worked out so let's see how things
have worked out for these two teams
yesterday
rocky's trying to strike early trevor's
story
1-0 travel whip it
fair just inside the third baseline
it'll roll down onto the track tapia
scores they're going to sand mcmahon a
two-run double for
story jana vanda will lead off the
rocky's second rakiti shakes off the
sign now the 2-2 is hit well down the
left-field line hooking towards the
corner but it is gone
touch him all time
yadav and dazza
here's mike trout batting two outs going
on no score and he swings at the pitch
and lifts a high fly ball that's
carrying deep out into right field in
his travel here
home run number six for mike trout
power for trout as home run power can do
damage here it comes deep center field
gone
and adoles has put the rangers in front
of the eighth inning five three rangers
[Applause]
and now a fresh series for these two
teams the angels and astros get going
and
the angels are checking in at nine and
seven on the year they're just a game
and a half out of first and hey the
oakland a's are on another planet right
now they just cannot stop meanwhile the
uh astros were off to a super fast start
and then they've fallen now a bit seven
and ten but you can see it's super
competitive jim they're all very close
together yeah and with the angels they
still do have you know there's a ton of
names but they do have the best player i
would say in major league baseball over
the past what it's been like a decade
now i i mean whenever you talk about the
number one and the best player in
baseball it's mike trout you know for me
i mean
he's consistent every year he puts up
great numbers and it's here at the
network i know it's a joy for us to talk
about him so i think we're going to dive
in here
to a little bit so last year last year
obviously what a rough year in general
for everybody and you know you look at i
mean
here he goes he goes deep to center he
goes to left field here on a breaking
ball he goes to left center now we're
going to go into this year early in
april same thing the leg kick he's
always in position to get ready there's
a ball out in front of the plate that he
hits into the seats and deep left center
now he goes oppo
and that tells me he stays on the ball
interestingly scott he's got a flat bat
on his pre-set up okay
when he gets back to his backside the
thing i look for is the angle the knob
of the bat to the catcher and when the
front foot hits
that's where you get that that knob to
the catcher and that is the most
powerful position a hitter can be in and
that's why mike trout
does and is so consistent because he's
so true with his mechanics every day you
know if they said to me hey
go do a demo on mike trout
honestly like you would see no flaw
there's nothing you could pick out in
his swing from now to five years ago
that's how consistent he's been and it's
just been an absolute joy and pleasure
to watch this guy and it will be for the
remaining remaining of his career we
should just start messing with people
and showing breakdowns of the swing and
just picking random years because like
you said it just doesn't even matter
it's always the same consistent that's
what makes him so great and he's tough
on himself though jim too he might say
he said in spring training you know i i
haven't felt completely on in a year
he's criticizing his defense and saying
he needs to get better but that's the
talk of a superstar well the great
players are always trying to get better
and in their mind if they've lacked in
their mind not in baseball's mind but in
their mind they know they look in the
mirror every day and i'm sure mike
wanted to go home and work on some
things and you're seeing this year he
looks motivated he just had a child a
year ago so i'm sure there's peace every
day coming home
and i look forward to watching him you
know have a wonderful fabulous year
because he's going to humble human no
ego walks around not like he's the best
player on the planet and i mentioned
that because mike trout's going to be
miked up for this game yeah how about
that so you want to hear what mike trout
says during a big league game you're
going to hear that live tonight on
youtube when we have it for you and the
game is about 20 minutes away so we'll
also mix in our polls we're big on
youtube on asking you let's keep it
simple to start who's gonna win today's
game jim i'll ask you later but angel's
at third place and hey it's so early
nine and seven the astros at seven and
ten on the year pay attention to the
pitching matchup alex cobb who had to
start skipped just because of the way
the schedule worked out going up against
christian javier who gets called back up
very talented and was part of the rookie
of the year race last year in the
american league so we'll get to all of
that i'm psyched to hear trout trout to
words during the game and then of course
his actions so right on back with us on
youtube we'll talk to
supercreator on youtube matt antonelli
jared walsh of the angels will join us
and our picks to click jim's going to
tell you who's winning this one coming
up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that deserves a waffle that's over to
390 sign in left center
and first pitch crushing
oh man
lean into it here's a guy that throws
the ball 101 on one half of the inning
and the next one is the first pitch to
150 feet
man i mean that ball was crushed wow
that was ridiculous
and trout gets a hold of one into the
corner and left daddy got it
homer's in ten straight two run shot for
trout maddie i'm going with you to vegas
at some point great call now with this
kind of thing okay let's get that home
run streak going i mean everything going
to halo's way tonight
[Music]
in the lineup
jordon alvarez is back in the lineup
carlos correa is going to lead things
off the mlb game of the week live on
youtube astros and angels coming soon
hey if you don't know him already get to
know the name you're going to see him
tonight jared walsh is hitting 327 this
season with four home runs he's knocked
in 13 the ops that's really good if
you're not following ops over a thousand
jim that's good right that's pretty good
yes that's going to play in the major
leagues let's talk to jared walsh live
right now on youtube he joins us jared
how are you today and how's the season
going for you so far
i'm doing great uh thanks for having me
on season's been going really well and
hope to keep it rolling
so jared jim tomy here first of all
congratulations what a great start well
what a great run you've had since last
year you know i want to dive into a
little bit on the hitting end are you
with your cage work are you more of a
soft toss guy or are you a tea guy and
how has that helped you maintain what
you've been doing since last year
i'll dabble in tea a little bit but more
so soft toss and then high velo is
really my bread and butter you know you
see teams like the astros kind of
started it and the dodgers the high fast
balls at the top of the zone if you
can't hit that you're gonna struggle so
uh just trying to test myself every day
in my work is really something that's
important to me can you tell us more
about the swing changes and just tweaks
that you've made over the past year or
so simplifying things and also maybe
picking a thing up or two from some of
your legendary teammates
yeah uh you know getting to watch these
guys on a daily basis is just
unbelievable you know
seeing trout rendon poo holes those guys
approach on a daily basis has been
huge for me so uh you know having that
ability to lay off a tough 3-2 pitch and
take your walk is is something that i
want to continue to work towards and um
yeah it's been it's been great i just
felt like if i could get on top of the
ball and hit a few more line drives that
would really help me at the big league
level and that's what's happened so
uh something that i'm really happy with
so jared have you noticed since last
year especially this year are the
pitchers doing anything different with
you as far as you making adjustments to
to a year ago from
now uh yeah i would say a lot less first
pitch fastballs right down the middle
unfortunately so uh hopefully they get
back into that soon
also jared i mean
we go back to when you were drafted and
i actually i remember when you said this
39th round 2015 out of georgia and you
called yourself almost mr irrelevant i
mean what was that experience like for
you i mean hey we're going late in the
draft and how much do you take that with
you even into games like today because
you know you were overlooked by a lot of
teams frankly
yeah it sticks with me a little bit but
there's really nothing to be bitter
about you know uh i'm here in the big
leagues i get to play with a bunch of
future hall of famers and
you know get to play in a great division
live in southern california so no reason
to cry over spilled milk
so jared we read that you're a steelers
fan uh describe who made you a steelers
fan and who is your all-time favorite
favorite stealer
oh
goodness
that's a tough question i'd probably
have to say heinz ward and a huge
steeler fan when i was a kid we had
season tickets we lived in georgia but
would fly to pittsburgh for steeler game
so my parents you know
huge pittsburgh sports fans so what an
experience that was growing up what's
that like in the clubhouse too because i
know your friend
and superstar teammate mike trout thinks
that the philadelphia eagles are a
pretty big deal i know he talks about
them a lot so what what's it like inside
the clubhouse with guys rooting for some
of their squads
you know once september rolls around and
the football's coming on every sunday
the clubhouse gets pretty rowdy because
everybody's got their team and their
fantasy team so uh you know it's a lot
of fun a lot of smack talk goes on about
all sports so uh it's something that's
that kind of you know keeps a tough
season easy to go through a lot of
failure in this game so anytime you can
have fun with your teammates and have a
little banter back and forth it's good
can you give me an example of whether
it's today when you walk into the
clubhouse or just something in the past
week that an exchange that you have with
you know name it mike trout anthony
rendon
justin upton something casual something
that you know someone watching at home
at youtube can just say all right these
are normal dudes because we look at them
as such superstars in their own way
shohei ohtani of course overseas for a
long time and now coming to a major
league baseball for the past few years
as a two-way player like we've never
seen and then also you know poo holes in
what he's done so just give me like a
common phrase that someone might say to
you
common phrase i don't know if i have
that um i was able to grab a steak and a
glass of wine with shohei which i would
assume you know that's
everybody's dream especially those
growing up in japan so you know getting
to meet people from all over the world
just to play baseball has been really
special you know doesn't matter if you
speak spanish japanese english we're all
friends inside the clubhouse well and
you have something in common with otani
you can throw the baseball from the
mound pretty well too jared so have did
have you guys discussed that and and can
you tell the youtube fans about your
experiences on the mounds and if we'll
see that again at some point
yes i was a brief two-way player but
pitching hurts so i don't do it anymore
and he and i don't really talk about
pitching mostly hitting how much though
could that have helped you as a hitter
do you ever think about you know the
mind of a pitcher when you have been on
the mound in big moments and what guys
are trying to throw at you and like you
mentioned earlier hey he's not getting
heater's first pitch right down the pipe
anymore they they know about you jared
but how can your pitcher brain um from
your experiences help you as a hitter
uh just remember that everyone's human
you know it's you're never gonna be
perfect so
i wouldn't say put too much pressure on
yourself because i mean i'm sure tommy
can speak to this sometimes you'll get a
[ __ ] right down the middle and you just
pop it up you know so uh uh don't give
anybody too much credit just play your
game have a little fun so jared for me i
got one more question who had the
biggest influence on you from either the
youth level high school level as you
were coming up or maybe it was your dad
who had the biggest influence on you for
baseball
my mom lisa walsh
when i was a kid my dad had cancer so he
had to get a surgery uh and wasn't able
to throw anymore so my mom threw me
batting practice my parents drove me all
over the southeast to travel baseball
games you know help pay for my college
just can't say enough about him
that is awesome that's great that is
really cool jared and last one on my end
for the big time pre-game meal and if
you're that kind of guy what are you
doing before games are you going real
heavy are you keeping it light what are
you eating before a game like today
you know i've done a terrible job at
answering almost any question you've
asked me so far
i would say the venti cold brew from
starbucks is kind of what i need
pre-game rolling up to the field so food
not necessarily but i need a little
caffeine running through my veins you're
way too hard on yourself you did great
you were awesome jack first time talking
to you and i'm sure it won't be the last
and congrats on your success so far and
good luck in this game tonight and then
the rest of the way this season it was a
pleasure talking to you
thank you guys stay safe
he is cleaning up in the lineup tonight
and well caffeinated the mlb game of the
week live on youtube presented by chime
is under 15 minutes away
it is time for our youtube creator
spotlight he's a former big leaguer he's
a former first round pick and he's been
on the youtube game for a long time the
channel is antonelli baseball matt
antonelli not only played in the bigs
not only went through
the college ranks and the farm system
but then afterwards said you know what
i'm gonna go over instructional videos
mechanics also give you a little taste
of what it's like to be a big leaguer
and let's chat with matt right now matt
how are you and i will start by saying i
drafted you in my minor league fantasy
draft about 15 years ago so i've been
following your career all the way back
pretty much when it started as far as a
pro
well thank you so much it's great to be
here and like i said earlier i could
have disappointed you there was a few
good years in there but a couple of bad
ones as well so sorry about that hey
i'll take the ups and downs the
development and you learned of course a
ton going through that system and then
have been sharing with the world what
you went through as a minor leaguer what
you've learned so let's just start there
with the channel
where did the idea come from and did you
ever think it would get to this point
where there are so many people
benefiting from what you're doing
no not at all i started my youtube
channel actually while i was playing i
always
had a vision of myself coaching one day
and it started a little bit earlier than
i probably expected but i was able to
learn a lot during my playing career
played for five different teams and
played for a lot of great coaches a lot
of great managers and just took bits and
pieces from all of them and was able to
pass that along one of my passions is
really you know passing that information
along the young kids and helping them
improve their game so i've been lucky to
do that over the last few years let's go
over feedback and views what's just pick
out one of your hottest videos that
you've ever had which one really racked
up the views and is there a reason why
well i think the youtube channel really
took off when i started to give some
insight into my playing career both at
the minor league and the major league
level um and i i think probably even
more minor leagues up in the major
league stuff i think a lot of fans and
people in general don't exactly know how
the minor leagues work so a lot of those
popular ones were you know how much do
minor leaguers get paid and and what's
it like coming up through the ranks and
so those are probably the most popular
ones but really anything talking about
the game of baseball
has been enjoyable for me and i think
it's been pretty popular
yeah let's let's go over the getting
paid thing just specifically we joke and
chat about it here at mlb network some
other hosts um about
how it looks in the bank account i don't
need numbers or anything i want to more
know you know when you were playing for
the padres
does it pop up in direct deposit or on
the check like hey padres or what's that
looking like
well when i signed i didn't know how to
write a check i didn't have any money i
i didn't know anything so i believe it
was put right into my account um
but some of my favorite stories when i
got drafted and luckily i was signed
pretty high so i had a pretty good
signing bonus but a lot of players
aren't that fortunate and i used to talk
with people all the time and they say
you know how much you're getting paid in
the minor league couple million dollars
and i'd say i think i made about 5 000
last year and most couldn't believe me
so um like i said a lot of
misconceptions but hey once you get to
the big leagues it makes up for all
those small checks if you get paid in
the minors yeah the big bucks the big
names too so tell the world if they
don't know already who your first career
knock was off of
so my first career hit was off of greg
maddox um so i can tell the grandkids
and my kids about that and uh it's funny
i was pretty nervous going into that
game as i'm sure most players are making
their debut
i got i was hitting eighth in the order
so i didn't get to hit the first inning
i played defense had a ground ball hit
to me first batter of the game russell
martin hit me a ball
and i fielded that ball made the throw
to first and all of a sudden i felt like
this calmness come over me so thankfully
i did that before i got in the box
because when i did hit it it honestly
felt like another just another at-bat
for me i got a fastball hit a single to
center field rounded first base and said
man that's pretty easy i think i'm going
to get like 3 000 more of these and i
think i had like 11 or 12 more hits in
my career so i was a little off on my
project uh prediction um but yeah to be
able to get a hit off at him a hall of
famer uh something i'll always remember
yeah that's awesome and that's great
video and of course i'm glad that we
have it let's finish with this uh any
comments or feedback whether it's just
something crazy or silly or something
from a fan or somebody that's been
impacted saying hey you really helped me
with my career any kind of feedback that
you've received on fee on youtube that
you can share with us
sure i think one of the most rewarding
things for me is the feedback and it's
not just you know helping kids in
america but helping really players all
over the world and the power of the
internet and youtube is amazing i talk
with with parents with coaches
with kids from literally every part of
the world pretty much every day i
receive emails and and different
comments on our social media platforms
and so
just being able to take a little bit of
something that i learned and i
understand how hard this game is and how
it can be frustrating at times because
it is a game of failure being able to
give those players some hope and maybe
just something small that helps them you
know improve a little bit and and get
through the next game or the next
practice and so that really is what uh
gets me motivated and keeps me doing
what i'm doing matt you've been crushing
it and i've been calling these games for
youtube for years now and seeing you in
the live chat with your commentary
looking forward to seeing you during
this game as well and a pleasure
speaking to you person to person for the
first time
absolutely thank you so much
he's great you'll see his comments in
the live chat hey you're going to have
superstars power athleticism i also want
to mention
contact jose iglesias david fletcher is
incredible in that department same with
michael brantley contact specialist some
of the best contact hitters and they've
got pop too in all of major league
baseball in all of the planet angels
astros is just five minutes away and
we'll do our picks to click in a moment
[Applause]
this ball hit hard again michael
brantley home run for the third straight
opening day
every year as an astro michael brantley
has been a home run uncle mike what
other teams are saying uncle on opening
day they're saying mike uncle
alex bregman on a 2-2 pitch
drives one deep to left field that
ball's gone back to back jacks bradley
and pregnant and the astros now lead 5-1
back-to-back bangers
jordan sends one in the air to center
field well hit going all the way back to
the wall that ball is gone
the big man you're not alvarez hits one
to left center field a three-run shot
and the astros take a 5-1 lead there we
go we got liftoff that is not an easy
pitch to get and that's out on the
outside corner and jordan stays on it
steps on it and drives it
you're watching the mlb game of the week
pre-game show presented by
chime carlos cray is leading off first
time in his career it's gonna be fun jim
yeah i like that i mean you know
obviously the athleticism is there he
can run
and sometimes like sometimes moving a
guy up the lead off or even as your club
can spark you and get you going i like
it we'll see how that looks and now i
got a bunch more questions for you it's
picks to click presented by fanduel
sportsbook so let's run through things
and also just for the youtube crowd to
understand you're going to have plenty
of poll questions coming your way during
this game so jim are you ready i'm ready
okay so what's number one here let's
start with
other than mike trout okay so you can't
pick the guy we're about to see who
would be your pick for al mvp i'm gonna
go jose abreu winning it back to back i
love when you look at the whole dynamic
of his game the team he's on they have a
chance to win and his work ethic
i like 60 rbis in 60 games was
impressive yeah you know what a what a
great player and uh it's fun to watch
him i'm going jose abreu
that's a great call so you think he can
do it back to back i do
i like it okay now i want you to focus
on this game in particular okay so the
over under for tonight's game total runs
is eight and a half are you going up or
down
and i'm gonna go under yeah i'm gonna go
down yeah yeah for some reason the the
pitching match up cobb and uh
yeah i do i do you know christian
javier's got the really good slider
curveball and then this thing cobb
throws as the thing that's the hybrid
split changeup you know i watching him
the first series i think against the
white sox he had that that ball was
really moving and it'll be i think it's
going to be under for sure i mean and it
plays to what we've been seeing the last
few years especially just less fastballs
and relying on him we've seen that from
cobb more relying on the thing and we'll
see that uh at play okay what about um
your favorite in the american league
west because this division looks like
pretty much anyone's game at this point
not because of the way they're playing
right now but oakland is a team you
always have to watch they do everything
fundamentally sound they pitch well they
do they hit good with two strikes as
they progress during the year they're
always a club to watch and for some
reason i think they're gonna win the
west no doubt did you fall for the slow
start from the a's because it was rough
i mean what they were one and seven to
start the season
yeah well you know and i don't look look
you can't win a championship in april
but you can sure put yourself behind but
it's how you bounce back from those from
those bad times and i think the overall
the years that that oakland has done
this there's confidence and melvin i
think does a fabulous job for them and
he always has them ready to play one
more quick one for you who's going to
win the american league i like the white
sox i like their bullpen i like their
starting pitching i think there's
another club that as they keep doing
this as they climb during this long
grind of 162
i think that bullpen and that and that
starting pitching will uh will put them
in a position to win the american league
yeah young but still has that veteran
yes and you mentioned to bray you're all
in on the white sox i love the white sox
and i i just think they're built right
now
for major success all right and so uh we
have the answer to the poll question
that we
ran through for you earlier and angels
fans going big tonight jim who's gonna
win today's game and they say alex cobb
and mike trout and albert pujols and
shohei otani and company and jared walsh
our guests from earlier so who's your
pick for this i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
the angels i think yeah i think when
trout's hot right now ohtani as well and
this this pitch that cobb i look forward
to seeing this tonight he he's very
crafty and he knows how to pitch it
should be an all-around great game so
you heard it here from jim low scoring
game-ish
and angels are taking it by the way as
we're under a minute from taking you to
the broadcasters for this one uh live on
youtube angels and astros i'll just i'll
put this in like a super plug early
tease jim and i will be calling next
week's game yes indians and twins live
on youtube la troy hawkins is going to
join us as well really two of the nicest
humans on the planet i'm going to speak
for you thank you yeah we're gonna have
a lot of fun and latroy is such a great
dude too yeah it's gonna be great so
we'll hang again next week but for now
it's all about the houston astros and
the los angeles angels and as you can
see alex bregman's in there tonight for
houston astros are trying to get back on
the winning side of things it's been a
minute slow start for this team mike
trout what are you saying right now well
guess what we're gonna know what he's
saying during the game he will be mic'd
up you'll hear plenty of sounds from the
greatest player on the planet have fun
enjoy the game
[Music]
[Applause]
are you
[Applause]
downtown houston where the only positive
thing to come out of the pandemic is no
traffic in a big sprawling downtown
community ready for baseball from the
space city tonight welcome to the mlb
game of the week live on youtube
presented by chime tonight from minute
maid park a battle in the ale west
between the los angeles angels and the
home standing houston astros
[Music]
and welcome to a worldwide audience on
youtube tonight about a game and a half
separating the astros and angels in the
als too early to make any determinations
about teams trending upward or downward
in a very competitive division we can't
tell you this the astros are happy to be
home after a rough road trip in which
they lost four out of five culminating
in a frozen loss yesterday playing in
the coldest temperatures ever for an
astros team in denver and the angels on
the other hand happy to be on the road
they're happy to be anywhere off to a
great start the angels opening a 10 game
road trip with their first of this four
game series in houston a little note on
what you're watching tonight this is the
second of 21 live major league baseball
games exclusively presented on youtube
can't watch this one anywhere else it
streams live globally on mlb's youtube
channel for free almost 3 million fans
subscribe to mlb's youtube channel and
click the bell icon receive
notifications prior to upcoming games
this is going to be a lot of fun for me
tonight because i'm working alongside
two guys who know these teams intimately
two guys who've each won a world series
ring uh two guys who both played in the
big leagues for 15 years i'm the only
guy by the way on this telecast without
a world series ring or a pocket kerchief
tonight we say hello to mark goobazza
and jeff blum hey gooby let's start with
you and dig on the angels it's powered
by a couple of guys their drive that is
who we're off to blazing starts
shogeotani and mike trout and for mike
trout we know about the accomplishments
right a closet full of trophies and
awards the only thing missing is a
commissioner's trophy in here al rookie
of the year
twice an all-star game mvp a room full
of silver slugger awards
and three
three
mvps he's gotten off to good starts in
the past gooby as you've watched over
the years
this year is one of his best
yeah matt it's been unbelievable for his
batting effort just under 400 it's on
base percentage at 507 the slugging
percentage leading major league baseball
and he showed a lot of enthusiasm he's
got a couple big key hits as he normally
does for the angels but he's pumping his
fist he's totally into getting this team
on his back getting into postseason all
those questions in spring where are you
going to get to the postseason he's
saying right now i'm going to deliver
the numbers that he has so far for the
halo this season take a look at this i
mean to those that suggest mike trout
hasn't played long enough enough to be a
hall of famer right now we offer this to
contend with that thought
through
1268 games that's where trout is right
now look at the career comparison this
grabs your attention
yeah ken griffey jr is a contemporary i
remember facing him a number of times
and seeing the enthusiasm of defense and
center field but the numbers and how he
could carry a club mickey mantle willie
mays ken griffey jr compared to mike
trout he knows that's a lot of pressure
but he's thriving on that pressure being
put on him jeff let's talk about the
astros pardon the old west pun but last
year as defending ale champs it was the
not okay corral in the space city the
regular season was not a good one justin
verlander
arm injury and made one start injuries
cost jordan alvarez what would have been
his follow-up to his rookie of the year
campaign the prior season carlos correa
not himself last year in the regular
season same with jose altuva yet despite
all that they turned it on in the fall
and came within one game of another
world series appearance jeff you watch
this team every day there's just too
much talent here for them to stay cold
for very much longer
yeah and carlos cares lead the way for
me because he is one of those guys that
is going to be a part of that massive
free agent shortstop class at the end of
the season expect him to have a big year
but jordan alvarez getting him back in
that lineup full time is going to be a
nice power source for dusty baker to
insert in there and hopefully drive in
runs you see these 60 extra base hits in
his first 100 career games is legendary
already but this guy right here dr
smooth we call him uncle mike in houston
just because he has been so reliable in
what he does both statistically and what
he brings that clubhouse he is really a
guy that can give them some comfort
during some tumultuous times this
vintage of astros baseball is really an
elite team they are one of only five
clubs to reach in lcs in four or more
consecutive
post seasons and looking for big things
once again today we're going to have a
lot of fun tonight for this one not only
are we with you for innings one through
nine and then post game show we have a
fourth member of our broadcast crew
tonight as well as we say good evening
to brett dolan thanks maddie well
astro's general manager james click
before the season said he needed his
superstars to play like superstars for
this to be a successful season well to
say the least in the first week things
worked out well houston won six of its
first seven games the team was scoring
more than seven runs a contest the
earned run average was very low but
things have changed and changed in a
rather dramatic fashion the strokes have
lost nine of ten games you barely
recognize their ops and the team era has
gone way up now of course this does come
with an explanation the astros had five
players put in the covet protocols
jordan alvarez martine maldonado alex
bregman and jose altuve they got four
back just in time to play in freezing
cold temperatures and snow flurries in
denver colorado but still no altuve yet
so dusty baker was asked yesterday
whether or not he has addressed this
slow start with this team or if he's
held a team meeting he said i need all
my team to meet to hold a meeting
meaning altuve who could be several more
games so the team is back they're out of
the snow it's the first of eight games
at home and hopeful that dusty can get
his team back the way they were playing
in that first week of the season maddie
brett thanks and the warm weather of
houston texas never looked so good to a
chilly group of astros yesterday in
denver when we come back it's time for
lineups and the opening pitch the angels
and astros are coming up next
bottom of the seventh inning the angels
trailing it five to nothing
they put the rally monkey up on the
scoreboard and this place went berserk
they've had so many rallies this year do
they have another one left in them
swinging a high drive deep to right to
the wall it's gone
it's io has made it a two-run game the
angels are breathing and right back into
it
there's a swing a long drive deep to
right it is gone
darren
with a home run it is a one-run game
the never say die angels giving their
fans a thrill down the stretch
said it belted left field in the gap
here comes diggins here comes anderson
the angels take the lead
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
are still breathing we are going to game
seven incredibly
[Applause]
welcome back to the mlb game of the week
live on youtube presented by chime with
mark gubizza at angel stadium jeff blum
and brett dolan at minute maid park i'm
matt vasquez great to have a worldwide
audience along with us tonight
welcome to the future gentlemen
live baseball on youtube you can only
watch the angels and astros right here
tonight
let's take a look at joe madden's angels
lineup to kick off this four game series
presented by chime
fletcher ohtani and trout out of the
gate mike trout opened a season with a
homer against the astros and he hasn't
stopped walsh upton and pujols bat four
through six iglesias rojas and suzuki
rounded out
the angels mark gubiza i'll start this
with you lead the american league and
homers along with a red-hot oakland ace
team and it's trout that leads the way
in that category
just absolutely crushing the baseball
393 with six home runs and 12 rbis going
against a very tough pitcher and
christian javier he's got a fastball
92-96 four-seam fastball upstairs slider
very good slider curveball and change-up
so far this season this is a 2.0
era in eight and two thirds look at
those strikeout numbers five to one as
far as strikeouts to walks yeah blummer
javier was down at the alternate site
this is his first big league start in a
couple of weeks but that was all by
design we understand
yeah it definitely was the astros had
the luxury of having some days off in
there so they've been able to send
christian javier out continue to throw
down in that alternate site they expect
him to give the astros about five or six
innings if everything goes accordingly
and like
mark goobas kubaza said that four scene
fastball is very good the astros like
spin rate and this is one of their spin
rate kings
let's take a look at the astros
defensively brought to you by chime and
nash american league lowe's seven errors
in their 17 games nice tight defensive
unit here blubber is is it is it range
and athleticism and flashy plays or are
they kind of more a workmanlike
defensive group
[Music]
they've got a little bit of both they
can do it with the flash especially a
guy like carlos correa who's a legit six
foot four six foot five at shortstop
shows great range but you gotta keep in
mind the astros highly analytical
they'll shift these guys and put them in
even better positions to make plays
underway on youtube tonight with the
first pitch of the game by javier in for
strike one
david fletcher shohei ohtani and mike
trout for the visiting angels
the numbers on javier's last start by
the way and it was two weeks ago to the
day five shutout innings in a six to two
victory struck out seven
allowed only three base hits and gooby
guys like this fascinate people like me
because he's not throwing 98.99 miles an
hour yet he can still make good fastball
hitters swing and miss
yeah it's that disappearing four-seamer
would spin on the upper third of the
strike zone
falling two strikes to david fletcher
[Music]
good take by fletcher on that slider huh
[Laughter]
blummer i've got to recalibrate to your
sense of humor man i haven't spent cons
i have not spent substantial time with
you in the better part of about 12 years
[Applause]
the strikeout for javier
how about the chime breakdown on
tonight's astro starter gooby
my three key points for him is
controlling that upper third of the
strike zone with his four seamer very
good as far as getting swing and miss
and pop-ups and finish with a slider six
strikeouts a 100 batting average versus
slider this year and better second time
through zero zero zero first time
through second time through 462 batting
average against javier this season
second time the hitters get to see him
show hey otani now with one a way to
start the night
ohtani has had a cartoonish start to the
2021 season
all over the statcast leaderboard in
terms of exit velocity with a bat in his
hands
and plain old
pitch velocity when he's out on the
mound
one on one
well he could generate some bat speed
i'll tell you what it's incredible what
he does when he puts the ball in play
you can see the astros right-handed
right side overload as blum talked about
a moment ago
jeff do they do they switch primarily
for uh for right-handed batters
sorry for left-handed batters or is it
on both sides of the plate that they'll
go into that shift
yeah you know what when they have altuve
in the lineup they won't shift as
heavily to the pull side on right-handed
hitters just because it's a little bit
longer throw for a guy like jose altuve
but when they have a left-handed hitter
up there they will shift drastically to
that pull side on the right side of the
field like you see on your screen
two balls and two strikes to ohtani
can i just say how envious i am of mark
goobazza and his
his ability to watch guys like mike
trout shohei ohtani on a regular basis
it's nice to see him 19 times a year but
i can't imagine what it's like watching
athletes of this caliber in baseball
right now as often as gooby does
two strikeouts start the game for
christian javier
you know what guys it's almost like
watching bo jackson together with shohei
ohtani and mike trout their skills
pretty nasty change-up
so two gone a couple of punch outs start
tonight and now mike trout who gets here
red hot five for his last eight huge
numbers to start the year six big boys
12 rbis javier understandably trying to
work him away missing with a slider a
ball and no strikes
trouts homered in back-to-back games
entering the series
if vegan homer tonight it would already
be
the second time this year
that he would have homered in three
straight
when these two teams split their opening
series in anaheim trout homered in the
opener
in the angel 7-6 win
astros come back and even it up the
following night with a victory that
included a big homer by carlos correa
javier has fallen behind three balls and
no strikes
trout doesn't swing at 3-0 all that
often but he has been more aggressive
3-0 this year
and one
well you know to blummer's point a
moment ago then the cartoony numbers for
trout
when he's ahead in the count since the
start of the 2019 season
he's got an ops
of 1700
and there's ball four
so trout's aboard with two gone and
that'll bring up jared walsh with the
big opportunity he too starts the series
hot
he's hit safely in five straight games
a five for 15 run
to wrap up the home stand
and of all the known commodities on the
angels guys like trout upton pujols
jared walsh is the guy that might sneak
up on the casual fan
but that's not to suggest that he's not
every bit as good as that aforementioned
list of blue blooders
and he takes a strike
i'm actually kind of curious to see this
matchup between christian javier who has
that good fastball in the upper portion
of the zone
jared walsh has the reputation of being
very good on hitting the fastball and
driving it
on the strike
yeah he's hit the four-seam fastball at
a 400 clip this year so in
javier there's a lot of four-seam
fastballs upstairs about 60 percent of
the time but those four seamer so good
matchup you're right blumber about this
one walsh versus javier tonight
trout aboard with sugan underway in the
top half of the first and it's a ball
and a strike to jared walsh
a little snap throw down to first and
trout never got too far off the bag hey
here's what you guys are talking about
walsh against the elevated heater
is slugging percentage since 2020
619
but if you go up top that 696 slugging
percentage is seventh best in baseball
and the guys ahead of them
are the guys you'd expect to be on that
list nelson cruz matt chapman xander
bogarts likes the high gas
and he lays off three balls in a strike
but the interesting thing about that
you're talking about right-handed
batters not many left-handed batters
prefer fastballs elevated they use the
lower third of the strike zone to do
their damage
three balls into strike account to jared
walsh
full count now
challenged him
yeah that's that stealth heater right i
mean it
it's the kind of fastball that you you
watch a guy take a swing and a miss at
and on his way back to the bench he's
looking out to the mound thinking how
did i not how did i not hit that
yeah i'm sure gooby could speak to it a
little bit better but the spin rate even
on the fastball it will plane out it
won't have the usual effect that gravity
will pulling the ball down in the zone
and he gets a lot of swings underneath
just like that
three strikeouts nothing comes with the
two out walk underway in houston tonight
here's mike trout batting two outs no
one on no score and he swings at the
pitch and looks a high fly ball that's
carrying deep out in the right field it
is trouble here
home run number six for mike trout
damage first pitch power for trout
connie hitting 304.
ohtani hits a high fly ball to right
field to the wall
goodbye a little showtime in the daytime
garcia has home run power can do damage
here it comes
[Applause]
well struck
high in the air deep center field gone
garcia again
and adoles has put the rangers in front
of the 8th inning
he doesn't mess around with the
excitement in the celebration and this
is tremendous power so here's low at the
plate
that ball pretty well struck out to
right field that one is gone
back to back home runs big insurance run
and it makes it 5-3 rangers
back from inmate park let's take a look
at dusty baker's lineup card for the
first of four with the angels the astros
chime starting lineup tonight carlos
correa will sit atop the lineup guard
for the first time in his career dusty
desperate to generate a little offense
tonight
brantley's been good he bats second in
left field breckman alvarez and guriel
three through five kyle tucker in right
oledmous diaz miles straw and martine
maldonado the former angel
round things out it's alex cobb on the
mound for the third time as an angel
his
attempt at a third start about a week
ago
was a scratch because of a series lost
against the minnesota twins so it's been
a while for alex as well his last start
back on the 12th of april a really good
one that night mark goobazon 10
strikeouts at kansas city
had a nasty split working that night
and his fastball velocity is picked up
he's been touching 95 miles per hour
also a good swing in miss curveball as
well
a ball and a strike to the lead off
hitter carlos correa yeah leading off
tonight
blumer we talked to dusty baker about
that before the game
and uh
dusty while always optimistic
is kind of ready to shake things up a
little bit tonight for his guys
yeah he's got to do something the astros
1-9 in their last 10 games
having base runners on has been an issue
but they need somebody to ignite this
thing jose altuve when he was in there
was hitting 318 at the top of that
lineup and having miles straw move into
that top spot didn't work out and straw
seemed like the
logical go-to as far as filling that
space at the top of the order because of
the speed it was just the inability to
get on base and get things going for
this powerful offense in the middle of
this lineup
an astros lineup that hit just 176
during the recently completed five-game
trip
dusty's creeping up on a milestone win
we'll talk about that as we get going
here tonight still the ball and two
strikes on carlos correa
weird statistical profile for the astros
plumber they they don't
strike out
they're around middle of the pack in a
lot of the major offensive categories
slug ops homers
but there's not any traction at all with
this lineup at this
stage of the schedule
it is a team that relies heavily on
scoring runs via the home run and
usually with that high on base
percentage you start to see those two
run three run home runs where they can
really ambush a pitcher and put up some
big squiggly numbers per inning and give
their pitchers a little bit of a cushion
but here recently in this last 10 10
game stretch it has been hitting with
runners in scoring position where
they're hitting around 163 in their last
10 games so the inability to drive in
runs has been a real issue
[ __ ] out to correa here's the payoff
pitch home and carlos squares up on a
ball and sends it into center
dies for trout
and the first doubt is in the books for
alex cobb gooby let's break them down
tonight
yeah my thing got to be careful on the
first pitch 375 batting average against
him this year 368 in his career and
swing and misses with a split 13
strikeouts with a splitter this year and
ground ball action for alex cobb 58.6
ground balls this year for alex cobb
to go to work on michael brantley now
who along with yuri guriel has been the
only kind of consistently reliable bat
for dusty baker to start the year
and brantley takes a strike
michael just over 300 for the season
right around where his career average
sits not ironically
he's never really had good looks at alex
cobb over the years just one for 10.
they'll make it one for 11 as iglesias
makes the play for the second out
let's take a look at the the arsenal for
him gooby via statcast 3d
yeah his power sinking fastball will get
a lot of ground balls but man he throws
a lot of splitters
45.4
in his knuckle curve you look where
every one of those pitches are at for
the most part lower third if you're a
hitter for the astros that's where
you're tracking lower third of the
strike zone
[Music]
33 year old right hander going back to
work on alex bregman now who takes the
first pitch out to right field and drops
it in for a base hit
[Applause]
what was that you're saying about uh
batting average on the first pitch
earlier
that's your best chance of getting a
fastball over the middle of the plane is
trying to put it in play
a little inside out approach for alex
bregman on a fastball inner half gets up
a base hit stolen base fred as well
hey is is that a coincidence i mean is
alex bregman the kind of guy that would
have known that information coming into
the start
yes 100 the astros do a very good job of
getting that information to these guys
and they do adhere to it troy snicker
and alex cintron the two hitting coaches
for the houston astros are very good
about getting that information to those
guys
so brickman's aboard and here's your don
alvarez
2019 al rookie of the year two homers
for him to start this season
and back in the starting lineup for the
first time since april 13th tonight
alvarez one of the astros bummer that
you mentioned sidelined while going
through the health and safety protocols
and limited to pinch hitting duty in
denver
and good to have him back out there
tonight
[Music]
yeah he really burst onto the scene in
2019 with some prodigious power
but it was pretty amazing to watch him
hit above 300 also that season so he did
a great job of
strike zone recognition
getting some pitches to drive and when
he barrels them up they have a tendency
to go a very long way
it's going to be interesting to see the
timing for some of these hitters like
bregman alvarez maldonado who came off
that
injured list
thing swung on and missed that's what
that's what alex cobb calls his split
change hybrid pitch well how about the
company he's keeping on this list
first 100 career games most extra base
hits only joe dimaggio
had more
quick throw first is closer than it
should have been
a ball in two strikes on jordan alvarez
i know the astros don't run a lot
like they used to but the rangers just
in town against the angels that was a an
effort by the angels to give kurt suzuki
a better chance of throwing out runners
by holding the ball and quicker the
first base on their moves
yeah neither one of these teams run a
lot i mean nobody runs a lot let's face
it but four total bases
four stolen bases that is for the astros
the angels with five
two of the smaller totals in all the
game i mean outside of a few individual
players ramon laureano tim anderson we
could name i guess a couple
the league doesn't run anymore
thing coming up here split change
no
or was it and one that just caught too
much of the plate
first and third with two gun what was
that gooby
that was a fastball he tried to sneak
one down when you look at the numbers
this year
for
alvarez versus sinker 83. he went with a
path though it ended up being a splitter
they kind of got around it
sometimes it'll cut like a slider got
too much of the plate that's why i
thought it was a fastball it's flat
right back up the middle good swing by
udon alvarez not trying to pull that
no gooby you're right that split
flattened out a little bit and you're
done you could see him leaking over the
outside corner had to pull his hands in
to get that but i'm even more impressed
with the fact that alex bregman went 180
feet from first to third
that shows me his legs are looking
pretty good
so a little two-out micro rally
developing here for houston now it's
julie gurio
off to the best start of any astros
hitter in 2021
alex brakeman had some issues in spring
training with some hamstrings he said he
put on about 15 20 pounds
and that time on the engine list may
have done him a little bit of good
moving around well going first to third
that's a good sign for astro fans
three balls and no strikes to count to
julie guriel who is the only astro
hitter
that has walked more than he struck out
to start the year
left-handed hitting right fielder kyle
tucker waiting next and guriel in a 3-0
count
[Music]
cobb gets a call in a high fastball
it's actually a really good pitch
he has been struggling a little bit this
year with that fastball inside
yeah i've seen him over the years really
good as far as hitting the ball hard to
right field against the angels
especially when it's out over the plate
suzuki sets up out there and the pitch
to guri else called for a strike
it's a pretty nasty combo to get back in
this count
yeah inside corner outside corner
what do we see next here gooby now what
playing along with this i'm i'm going
with the split i'm going with the thing
right here
[Applause]
i lost him with another knuckle
curve and that has loaded the bases
[Applause]
all right so how much of this gooby is
the fact that alex cobb missed his last
start and it's been a good uh
10 days since he's been out there
i'll be honest with you matt the worst
thing you can have for a sinker ball
pitcher especially with a split as well
is be too strong on the mound because
you're going to overthrow you've seen a
couple fastballs already the upper third
of the strike zone he feels too strong i
know it sounds odd but the stronger you
feel is a sinker ball pitcher the worse
you are because it's going to flatten
out as far as your movement on your
fastball
huge opportunity for kyle tucker who is
probably the happiest of any astro to be
off that dreadful trip through seattle
and denver one for 16 on the recently
completed five gamer
he's got the bases loaded with two goals
baseball is an amazing game it will put
you in spots
when you've been struggling like this
where the bases are loaded two outs and
your team needs a big hit to get things
going back home in their home ballpark
bregman alvarez and guri on the board
with two gone and a first pitch thing is
swung on and missed
those are the career bases loaded
numbers for tucker this year two for 21
with runners in scoring position
it's almost pat tabler like numbers for
bases loaded for tucker
0-2
for the uninitiated
pat tabler
who had a good career
was a completely different player with
the bases loaded
and i mean that as a positive
yeah he always told me he would be a 500
hitter if they didn't give an er to
edgar martinez at the third base against
randy johnson a couple i mean a number
of years ago so he was that good just
under 500 in his career with the bases
loaded
0-2 to tucker
because we're super reliant on
technology on a night light tonight
where the three of us are all in
different locations and i'm trying to
track pitches on my computer here in the
studio
my eyeballs tell me gooby more knuckle
curves than split changes so far
for alex cobb
so far you're exactly right on that
surprising
it's a feel for him on this on his
splitter right now the thing he's
frustrated as he delivered that one well
out of the strike zone he wants to make
it tantalizing enough for a hit or the
chase out of the strike zone but when it
starts that low you're not gonna get
chases
you know what gooby's exactly right when
you've got a guy with a good split in
your mind you're trying to zone that
pitch up if you see it down out of the
hand it you should tell yourself to lay
off it if it's low let it go
there's one a good one that he makes
tucker swing over the top up so the
strikeout gets him out of a bases loaded
two out jam we go to the second
scoreless in houston
[Music]
left fielder michael brantley hitting
327. hit sharply left side diving stop
story gets to his feet long throwing got
him
cold or not the defensive excellence of
trevor's story remains constant rocky's
trying to strike early
trevor's story
1-0 travel rip it
fair just inside the third base line
it'll roll down onto the track topia
scores they're going to sand mcmahon
he'll score from first a two-run double
for
jonathan dawson will lead off the
rocky's second and now the 2-2 is hit
well down the left-field line hooking
towards the corner but it is gone
touch him all time
jonathan
to give the rockies the lead
hits the ball hard to straight away
center field now towards right
diving catch by kyle tucker one of the
plays of the year for the astros austin
gomper who has pitched well this year
strong strong outing for austin gabriel
[Applause]
[Music]
hey another fun aspect of watching games
on youtube is our interactive polling
feature which allows you to offer a
multiple choice response to questions
posed in the live game commentary
stay tuned as the results will be
revealed and discussed later in the
broadcast and we've got our first poll
question to kind of get you going here
tonight
uh and i think i think i could guess on
some of the responses here who's the
most most exciting player
not named mike trout ohtani acuna tatis
betts
i'm just disappointed there's no place
for me to fill in a uh my own response
because alejandro kirk is my guy
[Laughter]
oh man that's a tough one there's so
many great names there cunha jr so far
has done some things when you score up
on a pop
pop up the second baseman uh i'm going
with that as much as ohtani has done
acuna junior is my guy right now how
about you plummer
i'm i've got to go with kunya also i
what he did like ubi was talking about
it's it's the power that he has
the aggressiveness on the base pass but
when i saw him beat out a routine ground
ball to didi gregorius that sold me that
this guy is not only electric but he
plays hard yeah
ballin two strikes to count to justin
upton leading things off in the second
christian javier issued a two-out walk
in the first but did register three
strikeouts
and round to a scoreless opening tonight
there's no wrong answers on that list
but i will stand by my claim that
kirk is the most exciting player in
baseball for me because he's
he's five seven 270
and he mashes and that's four strikeouts
for javier
by the way they played at buki bets made
to end the game against the padres the
other day at san diego that was
unbelievable
yeah mookie's
pretty unbelievable with his ability to
make he made a couple of plays in the
world series last year
to help win ball games but that was a
heck of a way to finish one off
here's albert pujols now with one out
and the base is empty
and albert sends a high fly ball
foul some of his greatest conquests
along the course of his 21-year hall of
fame career right here in this building
and i don't mean to salt up oldie wounds
here plummer
but um
i'm not sure brad lynch has gotten a
clean night's sleep since that night
no that home run that he gave up to
albert pujols in that championship
series in 2005 i think they may have
actually had to replace
the plexiglass out there in left field
above the railroad tracks
but uh that that home run has has left
an indelible mark on this community
watching albert pools over the years
following two strikes to count
how about alberta's last uh series
against texas picked up a stolen base is
115th of his career and then the next
night hits his 664th career home run so
and he's 41 years old
did i see some place where that made him
the oldest player to ever steal third
at 41. i mean i i don't know that many
older than that have ever done it
anecdotally unless somebody can google
that and tell me i'm wrong
and he's he hasn't been caught 13
straight
to tell him to sleep
let's go back to the homer we talked
about back in 2005.
game five the nlcs we've got liftoff
[Applause]
you know what's crazy about that home
run that home run actually had an impact
on the 2005 world series that the
ashevilles actually got to
because it forced roy oswalt to pitch in
game six and not start game one of that
o5 world series wow
two god and five strikeouts for
christian javier
jose iglesias i'm not sure what's going
on at that alternate site
doesn't the term alternate site just
sound
creepy mysterious i mean it sounds like
you know like they're they're
testing a nuclear reactor someplace
uh away from the watchful eye of the
federal government alternate site we
couldn't do any better than that
wait for a stranger things episode to
start yeah
boy christian javier's got every pitch
working tonight and it's a ball and a
strike to jose iglesias
this is the baby of the rotation at the
age of 24.
and the guy that was only pressed into
duty last year because
justin verlander became unavailable
yeah last year was interesting for the
astros pitching staff a lot of guys
making their major league debuts
and to your point maddie
christian javier ended up in third place
in rookie of the year voting
a disappearing 92 mile an hour fastball
upstairs looks like he can hit it but
it's by you
the one-two to iglesias
by the way i was just uh i was just sent
a tweet
matt burch by the angels pr staff
quick to remind me that ichiro stole
third at the age of 42
a year older than albert when he did it
this week
we just got to make sure we clean that
stuff up thanks matt
well you can yeah you never doubt maddie
burch he always has that
little side information to be able to
get us right two balls and two strikes
to jose iglesias
is he in swing mode or what man
hit over 370 last year
short sprint with the orioles had a
great season
10-year vet
career-highs last year in batting on
base slugging
celebrated his first homer as an angel
yesterday
the game the angels homered four times
in but still lost
christian javier mix in a ground out
dude
all six
via the swinging strikeout
[Music]
and trout gets a hold of one into the
corner and left daddy got it
two-run shot for trout
got him the thang
registering another punch out for alex
cobb
he's the 1-1 to otani
and that's hit well into the corner
that'll rattle around and right and
clear the bases
following two strikes
and shohei just taps that one back up
the middle
the overload hey he beats it out he's
allowed only one base runner on the two
out walk to suzuki last inning did
shohei get him get going get going to
right and gone
another rocket off ohtani's bat a base
hit to right
absolutely incredible swing again for
shohei ohtani three three-hit
performance
94 mile an hour fastball still able to
get the barrel to bat and he is locked
in and everything is being hit hard
here's the pitch and there's a ball
blasted out into left field it is out of
here
he did bust the game wide open it's a
grand slam and now it's 9-3 angels if he
knew it was gone is this a matter of how
far it was gone
back for the bottom of the second inning
no score in houston and for dusty baker
as we mentioned creeping up on the 1900
win club he is on the door
on the doorstep and once he gets into
the room he'll find the likes of bobby
[ __ ] walter alston sparky
john mcgraw almost 3 000 wins as a
manager connie mack and boach
and serving him up the bar
bucky harris joe mccarthy and still
winning games tony larussa that is quite
an exclusive club gentlemen
and taking all his teams five of them to
the postseason
oledmiss diaz hooks the ball into left
field and that'll bound up against the
corner
first extra base hit of the night oh and
diaz is able to stay on the bag
what the mary lou retton is going on out
there
yeah she's local i'm not sure she if
she's still giving out lessons but that
was a pretty dramatic slide in the
second base by oled miss diaz
[Applause]
that short porch here in minute maid
park that short porch in minute maid
park here creates some interesting plays
but that looked like it hurt dude that
is
right there that is top of the file for
why you have to stretch to play pro
sports kids
i mean you're going to tear a groin
you're going to tear something if you're
not ready for that play and here's miles
straw now
yeah that was a usa ufc fight i'm
tapping out right there after that slide
i'm done
straw the southern california kid
who has a big opportunity to play every
day in houston
fastballs in for strike it's worth
looking at that again
did a good job of staying down on that
pitch and yanking it into the corner but
about right here he realizes he's got to
turn it on
and i tell you what there was a
collective throne between the three of
us when that happened
curveball fouled away and it's a ball in
two strikes to straw
miles did not play yesterday
and has been slow to respond to everyday
opportunity this year world of talent
astros love him they wouldn't have given
him the keys to the job
in the george springer-less days that
ensue had they not been fans of mile
straw
and the thought is he'll come around
dusty baker telling us before the game
he had a heart-to-heart with miles
yesterday and wants him just to be more
aggressive at the plate jeff
[Music]
yeah you know what that was what was
interesting is ins when spring training
began for the astros there was an
obvious hole in center field in an
obvious hole at the top of the lineup
but having a guy like miles straw he
fits more of the traditional lead off
man type mentality where
take some pitches get on base create
havoc with his speed but it's been tough
going because he has been a little bit
more passive and i think dusty having
that heart to heart should help miles
straw calm down a little bit be more
aggressive on pitches he knows he can
get to
one thing that he has not done is laid
down that bunt in certain situations
and that might be something he has to
work on because it could be a valuable
weapon to get him on base
two balls and two strikes
sharply hit past the third baseman rojas
into the corner that's going to get diaz
around to score
miles straw driving in the first run of
the night and it's one nothing astros
a ball into the short left field corner
then he turns into a triple
that's speed on display one of the most
difficult things as a singer ball
pitcher with a man on second with no
outs is to try to get an out other than
a ground ball because you're a ground
ball pitcher 58.6
of the time it gets up by rojas and in
the corner and then you get to see those
wheels on display by miles straw
and that's also a very good view from
behind home plate that was a long way
for justin upton to go to get that ball
in the corner because to be be honest
also about miles straw he goes the other
way
a lot of the time he very rarely turns
on the ball so that was a tough play for
justin upton to get all the way in the
corner
here's martine maldonado now chance for
a fly ball to make it two-nothing astros
early tonight
and a couple of curve balls have him
chasing
maldonado re-upping a new contract
extension for him announced this week
has always been regarded as one of the
better
pitch handlers in defensive catchers in
the game rewarded for that
and he chases for a strikeout
second for cobb tonight one away
yeah three straight knuckle curves no no
thing there and that about it was the
knuckle curve it was so effective 250
batting hours with a couple of
strikeouts this year for that pitch for
alex cobb got a strikeout against
baldonado with three straight
i know it's a small sample size but
through alex's first two starts as an
angel he had the best chase percentage
of any pitcher the first few weeks of
the season almost 50 percent
he starts correa with a curveball for a
strike
it's a guy that's been through a lot
physically
along the course of his decade-long big
league career
broke in with the tampa bay rays against
the angels ironically
here's a look at that chase rate
45
yeah during in the offseason went up to
seattle the driveline to work on some
things mechanically
and a better fastball better command of
his splitter and same thing with his
knuckle curve
a ball and two strikes to correa now
hey gooby has he always been a guy that
started on that first base side of the
rubber because he really strides towards
that right-handed hitter and creates
that crossfire might create a little
more deception maybe
part of it he does that too is to be
able to make sure he gets inside with
some of his pitches that are lefties as
well he's been really effective against
left-handed batters this year more so
than righties
two balls and two strikes to correa
alex was never a lot of times go ahead
gooby
yeah a lot of times when you see a
pitcher on that side of the rubber
they're more sicker ball i always think
of a guy like derrick lowe
very successful pitcher starts their
beak sure to be able to run that fast
but a two seamer in a lefty to catch the
inside corner
and a ground ball that trickles through
the infield and allows straw to score
easily boy that's a two-strike count
that
just got away from cobb
went to a fastball there on two and two
and i think that made correa's job a
little easier
i agree
and i think if we see the free play
you're gonna see that
suzuki set up on the inside and this
ball tailed over the outside and correa
just punched it the other way
you talked about the low strikeout
numbers earlier in the game that's what
the astros do is they try and fight
those two strike counts and sometimes it
pays off
rbi for correa his eighth of the year
here's michael brantley now
[Music]
so the little tweak atop the lineup card
so far so good for dusty baker
because correa's turn came up with one
out and a runner at third
and their shortstop came through
two-nothing astros
once again the angels overload the right
side of the infield against the
left-handed hitting brantley
jeff do you get a sense that correa
could stick around in that lead-off spot
as long as altuve is unavailable or is
that going to be one of those
chairs that's rotated
you know what knowing that dusty is
approaching you know milestones with
managerial wins i think if they end up
winning this ball game and carlos correa
is on base a couple of times and driving
runners in and it looks like the offense
is picking up a little bit i don't i
don't think he'd move him until altuve
came back to be honest with you
i mean after all and you know this
applies league wide um
you know gooby willy wilson where have
you gone those guys aren't around
anymore the true lead-off hitter that
that we knew
the guy that got on base and ran
you could name him on one hand this year
and mike trout has been in that spot a
number of times for the angels in his
career reason why you get him an extra
at bat as the game progressed in that
lead-off spot because you're only a
lead-off man that first inning other
than that you have a chance to drive in
runs and get an extra at-bat later on in
the game
two balls in a strike to count to
michael brantley
carlos korea does not have a stolen base
attempt this year
you know i also get the risk reward of
the stolen base i understand why mike
trout doesn't run as often i understand
why a guy like carlos correa wouldn't
run as often
the injury risk is it's too great to
ignore sometimes
[Applause]
[Music]
still two balls
base runners are doing their best they
can to avoid some of those injuries
you're talking about matt a lot of these
guys are going out there with the oven
mitt approach
curveball in for a strike two and two
michael brantley of course returning to
houston on a two-year free agent
contract this year
after uh a heavy courtship from the
toronto blue jays
when many people thought he was going to
join join george springer and apply for
a passport and cobb strikes him out on
the thing the split change that's three
for alex copp tonight
hey everyone to know what it's like to
be a rookie in the big leagues join ryan
mount castle of the orioles on a behind
the scenes v-log journey on youtube.com
mlb
two runs in
two gone with the runner at first now
for alex bregman who singled back in the
first
ah and that one got him
cop came in with a fast ball got him on
the elbow
a couple things really on that pitch
right there for alex cobb strong
drops his wrist enough but it's going to
run up and in on the right-handed batter
instead of have sink action and that's
why he's able to hit
fragment on the elbow area
boy did that get him above the pads
it may have i hope it didn't
but that alex cobb threw the same pitch
that alex got a hit on in that first
at-bat swinging at the first pitch
fastball in so they were trying to do
the same thing that they did in the
first at-bat
but like gooby said just got away from
them
here's jordan alvarez now and again the
angels overload the right side
runners at first and second two runs in
yeah
oh yeah i don't know if it got it
sounded like it hit the pack the first
pass we took
and alvarez slices that one out of play
well you go back to this inning guys
miles straw with his speed created a
couple runs he hits that ground ball
down the line gets a triple and with the
infield in ground ball to albert pulls
he's thinking i got to be quick to
deplete with the speed of miles straw
unable to make that play on that
grounder by correa his way two run score
on this inning because of the speed of
miles straw
two balls in a strike
most rbis in his first 100 career games
walt droppo drove in 106 runs in his
first hundred games
oh man i mean you're talking about
some historical figures there
the only contemporary name on that list
is the guy at the plate
two and two
yeah i had no i had no idea
jordan alvarez was gonna allow for so
many walt dropo
references in my life
it's a good point i don't know that walt
would have come up tonight at all that
had not been for jordan alvarez
and i think walt got all of his rbis in
the first three years of his career
because there was a pretty drastic
drop-off after that
oh cop thought he had a call there
ran that fastball in on the big
left-handed batter and just missed and
now it's a full count three and two
play the guessing game with us gooby
what's he throw here on a full count
going split finger after fastball in
generally fastball up and in you go down
and away
the 3-2
went back up there with a fastball and
lost him and that loads the bases for
the second time in his many innings
yeah i'm surprised i was with you gooby
i thought he had him all set up for the
split change and here comes angel's
pitching coach matt wise
yeah you always love to go back up a
pitch like that with another back up and
in fastball but if it leaks out over the
plate at all we're talking about the
power for alvarez you're going to run
into some problems splitter down and
away he can hit a ground ball making a
run in but a big swing could result in a
three-run home run without fastball
stays out over the plate
[Music]
big plate appearance here for yuli
guriel
the astros would love to take further
advantage of what has been an inning
where they're runners on base throughout
they've cashed in for two of them bases
loaded with two gone now guriel walked
in the first
along with carlos correa eight rbis
early on to pace the team
and a guy that has been a real force
with the bases loaded
a near 500 hitter
takes a strike
in fact he's exactly 521 521-42 with the
bases loaded
this two-run homer
yesterday houston's only home run
in their last five games
and he's behind owen two
take you back to the snowy day in
denver for one time this entire season i
was glad we weren't traveling but he got
a hold of a curve ball from gomber and
drove it out to left center field
and that was pretty much the most
excitement those guys had other than
watching snowfall maybe for the first
times in their lives
dusty baker telling us before the game
today 60 years in professional baseball
and he could never
participated in a game in the snow
which we all found kind of hard to
believe for a guy that you'd think
had been a part of every circumstance
imaginable
yeah that one got me dusty baker has
seen
several decades of baseball and to hear
that shocked me a little bit
two strike count remains to you lee
guriel that one misses up and in a ball
in two strikes now
as a pitcher guriel is your worst
nightmare with the bases loaded because
he can hit the ball to all fields he can
hit all speed pitch as well he can hit
fastball as well and like i mentioned
before he's done a ton of damage against
the angels in his career
that ball wasn't even in the strike zone
and yank just
fouled
that's six inches off the inside corner
i mean
he does such an amazing job
go ahead yeah no to your point goofy i
mean where do you go where do you go to
get him out
the old rod crew scouting report throw
it right down the middle let him hit a
line driving somebody
yeah uli does a great job of pulling
that knob of the bat through so early
and there's so much lag on that bat that
it creates all kinds of coverage but
he's not a very discriminate hitter when
he's got rbis out there
oh man cobb shook suzuki off to get to
that fastball and just missed his spot
so now it's two and two
it's been a 35 pitch inning for alex
cobb and it has not been the breezy
results that he had 10 days ago in
kansas city
when he struck out 10 against the royals
2-2
easy take for guriel on the change
wow
a double a triple a single a hit batsman
and a walk this inning
[Applause]
base is loaded here's the 3-2 pitch
and he just missed with the split change
man didn't miss by much
an rbi for guriel is team leading ninth
three-nothing astros
[Music]
i'll tell you what guys
it's been really impressive to watch
julie this season
he's not typically a guy who is going to
lay off pitches out of the zone
in the past he hasn't been a guy that's
been
on base percentage type guy he's usually
been a guy that swings his way on to the
base pads but now this season with two
walks 15 on the season is a rarity for
yuli garielle
well he's already walked more than he
did last season
12 walks all of last year
15 this season and again the only astro
that's walked more than he struck out
it's a ball and no strikes to kyle
tucker a strikeout victim to end the
first that came to get cobb out of a
bases loaded jam trying to get out of
another here fastball in for his strike
we're going back to that take by gorilla
this is a short little stride he was
looking just to make some contact he
wants to take a grand slam he was
sticking middle of the field and making
contact and that's able to track it out
of the zone
two balls in a strike
an astros team that is among the most
disciplined in baseball fewest
strikeouts in the american league at the
start of play
they've been easy takes like that and
there have been some borderline pitches
that they've been able to stay away from
and that has helped move the line
in this run inning and now matt wise is
on the phone with the bullpen
three balls in a strike to tucker
and that's lined into cello right where
fletcher had him played perfectly to
avoid any further damage
the astros do crack the scoreboard for
three in the second
a long inning for houston
results in three big runs
astros on top early at home
[Applause]
yeah it was a really cool moment here a
lot of the fans were standing and
showing their appreciation for the times
when aj was the manager and i know it
had to be an emotional time for him
thompson has his first major league hit
ronnie dawson a little
fist pump as he heads down the line and
slaps his hands together ronnie dawson
congratulations his first major league
hit leading off the seventh inning with
a clean single left yeah get that
baseball first big league game tonight
on the ground right side that's a base
hit alex degote a single to right field
coming in to score correa the throw wide
at third here comes taylor jones he'll
score first major league hit give to
goatee a single and an rbi and giving
that baseball what a thrill for alex
taygodi
mccormick rips one to left center field
that ball is down and all the way to the
walls the goatee's spreading home but he
could walk home and chas mccormick in
the second base with an rbi double
three-nothing astro
brown ball hit to the right side into
the shift to his right diaz he fields
throws to first and the inning is over
eight shutout innings for zach frankie
welcome back three nothing astros top
half of the third earlier we had our
youtube most exciting player not named
mike trout player pole it's a mouthful
and shohei ohtani wins it in a landslide
with over 50 percent of the vote we'll
have another poll question coming up for
you a little bit later on
for now we welcome angels right-hander
dylan bundy to the telecast dylan
welcome man have you ever played with a
guy
uh even remotely as skilled and
interesting as shohei ohtani
uh i'm gonna say no i haven't uh i mean
a guy throws a 100 mile an hour on the
mound and then hits balls 450 feet so uh
there's not anybody else in the game
that does that so he's definitely the
one of the most exciting there you go
it's a fall into the opposite field from
jose rojas
and rojas gets that one off the top of
the wall
inches away
from his first big league homer
i really thought that ball was going
i think he did too
we're taking another look at the replay
here dylan and
how far up on that wall did it go man
yeah hit that hit that big garage door
so rojas happy with a lead off double
hey congrats on a great start to the
season man uh tell us about how you're
feeling tell us about the weird layoff
getting that
that series canceled against the twins
give us the report card
yeah it's been kind of a weird start to
the season with uh you know it seems
like we've had a lot of off days and
then the rain outs and uh or the weather
down in dunedin florida so
uh then they canceled with the twins so
yeah it's definitely weird but uh
you know we're doing the best we can and
trying to win ball games
so dylan talk about the comfort you've
had wearing that angel uniform an
outstanding year last year always
go out there and attacking the strike
zone and another good start of a season
this year the comfort with the angels
yeah thank you uh i don't know i mean i
get along with everybody here uh we have
a good i think good chemistry in the
clubhouse right now with these guys we
have here so
uh
good staff
you really can't ask for much and
new division uh
you know still trying to get to know all
these teams in this division now so
always learning uh
that's a pitcher definitely
[Music]
dylan jeff blum here from the houston
astros broadcast
and i was with you i thought that uh
rojas hit that ball out of here and i'm
kind of curious when you come into a
ballpark like minute maid park where the
dimensions are so unique do you have to
alter your game planning when you come
in here to face this team
oh no definitely
definitely don't do that i mean
uh you stick to the game plan whether
it's off
reading their swings or kind of the game
plan you want to attack with
whether it be off speed fastballs
whatever it may be but
i don't think you change based on the
ballpark dimensions though
or the shape of it
kurt suzuki pops one up behind the plate
and that'll get out of play
so dylan you're uh you're scheduled on
sunday
what what if if you're the last guy to
pitch in a long series like this one
what are your off days like are you
looking at video what do you do before
games leading up to your start date
yeah like a bullpen today
this is my third day after
my my last start so bullpen just to kind
of fill out some things work on a few
things if you want
and then just some light catch tomorrow
recovery
same thing the following day and then
get ready for your start
on sunday
there that one
suzuki sends one into the corner and
just foul
man it's deceiving we're in that we're
in the studio dylan we can't tell what's
going on we don't know whether to squat
or wind our watch half the time you got
a better view than we do
[Music]
dang that's two now maybe we should let
him give you some play-by-play
i mean it'd be better than mine already
do you think here's a question for you
because we're taking a look at the
ballpark now nice aerial shot
do you buy into the difference between
the roof open and the roof closed at a
place like this or do you not even care
i don't
read too much into it but yeah i've
heard those things like toronto
with the roof open closed versus you
know does the ball carry more
i'm sure it has an effect you know
depending on which way the wind's
blowing but uh
or how it comes into the stadium i guess
but i think you'd have to be the home
team to know what it does exactly by the
way did you just see that guy eat it
trying for the foul ball did you see
that
no dude just absolutely bit it i mean
there's partial attendance all around
major league baseball so when a guy
falls that spectacularly
we see it clearly i don't know if
there's a monitor in the doggy you're
gonna love this if you can see it again
balling two strikes by the way the count
to kurt suzuki
this guy went down you have to go back
and look at it
and kurt's paddling we're going to take
a look at it again dylan so bear with us
here check this dude out
oh you're good
yeah i've got the number for a good
spine specialist in town
oh
yes yes it happened kept it in front
though kept it in front of him
still a ball and two strikes on kurt
suzuki as we continue visiting with
angel's right-hander dylan bundy hey
dylan because we're on youtube tonight
and and gooby blumer and i are having a
good time with this
we've asked a lot of people including
your manager i'll ask you the same thing
what was the last instructional video
that you looked at on youtube to learn
how to do something
oh that's a good question uh
instructional maybe about an electric
bike maybe
well i don't know if that's too
instructional though well sure yeah i
mean to ride it to to build it i mean
yeah i mean i guess
yeah just how to how to work it i guess
and how the battery and brakes throttle
stuff stuff like that i guess on an
electric bike that's that's what it is
we had a pool going we thought you were
we thought was gonna be a hunting video
or a fishing video and we were wrong
about that well it's a well it is an
electric bike for hunting though
okay
it's got like really fat tires on it
it's got like really fat tires on it so
suzuki trying to get that one to stay
fair man
he's on him just can't get it to drop
into fair territory
[Music]
hey dylan how is it to throw to kurt
suzuki behind the plate man he's always
had a great reputation of working well
with pitchers
yeah a big fan i mean he's been in the
game for what 14 15 years now
a lot of knowledge back there and
anytime you have a guy like that with
his veteran presence back there you're
gonna you're gonna have a lot of trust
in him
two balls and two strikes it stays to
kurt suzuki
we're going to hang with you for this
at-bat dylan because so far so good
as long as it keeps
how many how many pitches is that
we got people that can tell you that
hang on
oh nice hey dylan does it drive you nuts
when hitter is fouling balls off like
this
yeah kind it's not fun
uh
you'd rather
you know put it in play or miss it
this is going to be the 11th pitch
coming up to kurt suzuki after the lead
off double by jose rojas
three-nothing astros what's the most 19
19 or 20.
wasn't it brennan bill that's a good
question i i don't know about modern uh
modern history but i know that last year
the longest buy in angels batter was
justin upton 11. so that's
where we're at right now with kurt
and i'm told dylan that the longest on
record is 21 a 21 pitch at bad
back in 1988
oof yeah
yeah that sounds terrible
not fun no
for the hitter too plumber yeah work
oh yeah
yeah i'm not i could stand up there all
day and say yeah i was up there fighting
some of these pitches off when in
reality i couldn't square one up
and suzuki finally succumbs to the
strikeout that's seven for javier hey
dylan we appreciate the visit man we
love watching you pitch and we'll enjoy
watching you pitch on sunday to wrap up
this series way to go
all right all right guys thank you thank
you dylan bundy joining us on the
broadcast tonight
i didn't ask you guys gooby what was the
last instructional video that you looked
at on youtube
uh you know cooking and making a philly
cheesesteak
believe it or not because i had to do
some little fun thing for the angels
being a philly guy you would think i
would know but no i had to
get a little instruction on youtube on
how to make one
man your secret is safe on south street
with me mark goobb is a philly guy
needed to youtube how to make a
cheesesteak
all these special ingredients yes
top of the order here's david fletcher
you had to watch a video for cheese whiz
huh
no i can't do that i had to go by
prevalent cheese
oh there we go plumber how about you
last youtube instructional video
i had to figure out how to
dismantle my garbage disposal and fix it
because
my beautiful wife put down an entire
head of lettuce into the garbage
disposal and locked it up
that's living in the house with five
women right there oh yeah
it's a fly ball into the corner that's
got a chance if it stays fair and that
one's foul
and it's owen two to david fletcher did
you did it work did he unclog it oh
i i was an absolute hero that night
didn't have to do the dishes
beers were brought to me it was glorious
christian javier has not done anything
but strike people out he's allowed a
walk in a double tonight and all seven
outs
on swinging strikeouts
well the way he's pitching tonight it's
hard to imagine his not being a part of
the opening day rotation plans
even if everybody's healthy
no very true especially with the issues
that the astros have had in their
rotation coming out of spring training
from valdez on the injured list with a
broken finger he's rehabbing and hoping
to be back by the end of may
and then jake odorizzi being added to
the rotation but he wasn't able to join
the team until two or three starts into
the season so
i agree with you in the sense that he's
got the stuff to play at this level it
was just a matter of fitting him into
the rotation and unfortunately
unfortunately he was one of the guys
that had to be sent to that alternate
site
when there were those days off came into
play
fallen two strikes to count to david
fletcher
second time through for him now see how
he reacts remember we talked about that
in the beginning 462
second time through for
javier so a little more difficult
especially this part of the order coming
up now for the angels with a man in
scoring position
and fletcher chases to strike out
but that if that's not a perfect pitch
breaking ball gets the very outside of
the corner
gosh you know what
if you're striking out dave david
fletcher
there's something good about that
breaking ball pretty impressive eight
strike outs tonight for javier ties a
career high for him last time he did it
was against the other los angeles team
you make a good point about striking out
david fletcher too jeff here's shohei
otani now with a runner at second and
two gone back-to-back strikeouts
fletcher's strikeout percentage since
the start of the 2018 season
is the second lowest in all of baseball
only andrewton simmons former angel
and joe panic a current blue jay have
struck out in a fewer percentage of
played appearances
it's owen one to otani
we check it out we got three of the five
lowest strikeout percentages in baseball
on the field tonight
because right underneath fletcher is
brantley and guriel on this list
he doesn't hit it hard but who cares
he doesn't barrel it but who cares he
hits 300 and doesn't strike out
ohtani had one to hit
but flies it into center for straw and
nothing comes to the lead off double
more impressive work by 24 year old
right-hander christian javier
[Music]
nice inside-out pass in an opposite
field base hit for shohei and the angels
have a one out base runner in the first
here's the 1-1 to ohtani
and that's hit well into the corner
that'll rattle around and right and
clear the bases
one too many fastballs against shohei
ohtani and the angels get their
three-run lead back in the seventh
shohei serves that into the opposite
field and that's going to drop in front
of ben and tindy and rolled all the way
to the track
fletcher coming around third and his
score
and it's an 8-3 angel lead
more damage by ohtani
that's his fifth extra base hit in his
last 11 at bats shohei ohtani
another rbi giving him three on the game
he's allowed only one base runner on the
two out walk to suzuki last inning did
shohei get him get going get going to
right and gone
the superhero does it again
number four for shohei ohtani what a job
by shohei
and welcome back to minute maid park we
have another poll for you and we'd like
to know which upcoming free agent
shortstop will get the biggest deal so
those watching in puerto rico you could
start voting for carlos correa now or
family members for story seeger or bayes
and uh
got a feeling all of those guys will be
paid quite well matty very soon yeah
brett thanks for that um man
i mean there's no wrong answer there
what a talent list lindor was on that
list of course but uh re-upped and going
nowhere outside of flushing queens for
the next decade
alex cop back to work and we'll get the
bottom third of the order for the astros
who lead it 3-0
maybe jake oderizzi has some thoughts on
that uh jacob or izzy joining us hey
jake thanks for taking some time man did
you hear that list of shortstops in
between baez seeger story and correa who
is the guy on that list that you'd like
to face the least
oh geez that's uh i don't know if
there's one you want to pick out of that
group i feel like they'd take offense to
it it'd be worse if you picked one so uh
i haven't faced seeger um
it's been a while since i faced baez uh
an interface story so i guess maybe all
three the three guys that i haven't seen
all that often i've seen carlos uh
plenty so uh i could do without that now
you know i don't have to worry about
that anymore since we're uh sharing the
same dugout yeah yeah hey and by the way
thanks for coming on with us
congratulations on your deal joining the
astros i know that the astros and the
fans were thrilled that you decided to
sign there ironically
the team that you were linked to so
often in the off-season is the astros
opponent tonight the angels
were reportedly hot on your heels too
tell us about the reasons you chose the
astros and the fit in houston
so yeah i mean the angels were one of
the teams that were you know talked to
us pretty much from start to finish but
um
ended up choosing here in the end i
thought it was a good fit from a from a
pitching staff-wise i've heard
tremendous things about strami
and uh
good pitch right there um
he
he does a lot of philosophies that i
trained with in the offseason has the
same thought process and there's been
some guys that have come here that have
had a lot of success um you know kind of
amplifying what they do well they make
it better so i was excited about that i
have a lot of former teammates on this
team um one of my
uh former catchers in minnesota jason
castro was here so i thought the rapport
of showing up late to spring training
and already having a picture catcher
relationship was a very important thing
to try to catch up as as quick as
possible so that had a lot of influence
on it as well
um
and you know the team in general you
know this is a very a very good team i
know we haven't played like it uh
probably the last 10 days or so but uh
you know hopefully we start turning
around but i think there's a lot of good
things ahead for us
here in the future
hey jake
you and alex cobb have a very good pitch
in your repertoire that split change is
there any similarity between your your
change and his split
does that go back to your time in tampa
bay together
yeah he's the one who taught me how to
throw the split i throw it a little bit
different i'm a little higher on the
ball than what he is but uh
yeah he was the one who who taught it to
me and uh you know it was kind of a
turning point in my career i was finally
had an off-speed pitch that wasn't a
breaking ball so
um yeah it was uh it's funny how you
know things come full circle and that
sort of thing but yeah i was very
thankful i was a rookie trying to make
the team out of spring and he went out
of his way and worked with me in spring
training helped me you know throw it
manipulate it and uh you know it really
changed the way i uh i pitched to this
day
so jake think speaking of how things
turn and come around you were traded for
zach grenke and now you're a teammate
with him how important it is to be
around him and learn how to pitch
because he's one of the all-time greats
yeah he's fantastic and
anytime you can sit and listen to zach
talk about
pitching um anything in general i just
want to sit there and soak it up because
then he has such knowledge when it comes
to it and has the reasons to back it up
not just like you know he thinks it's
this he thinks that he has
you know the reasoning behind you know
why he thinks something in there there's
data to back it up so he's uh he's
fantastic to be around and i know a lot
of the guys here
really like sitting and just listening
to him talk and it's not all that often
we get
wants to sit and talk but
it's it's great to just be able to have
a guy like that
on a in a rotation and he was the guy i
modeled myself after after i was drafted
i thought there was a lot of
similarities and now to be here
obviously we've been traded for each
other it's it's really weird how that
works out but i'm just trying to pick
his brain and learn as much as i can
from him
every single day
yeah that's actually interesting that
you talked about that because i know
after your last start at minimade park
you had talked about possibly getting
near justin berlander
but talk about
you know what you guys talk about as a
as pitchers in minute maid park did they
offer any uh you know tidbits on how to
handle pitching in a ballpark because
you got snake bit by a couple of home
runs in that crawford box
yeah that was uh that was a tough intro
to uh oh there we go
boy that's a ball that's
four inches in on his hands and and
carlos correa lines it into center well
loops it into center for an rbi base hit
what a fine job at the plate by carlos
correa four nothing astros
[Applause]
yeah so going back on my it wasn't the
most ideal uh start to my astros career
that's for charlotte liked something a
lot better than what it was but um
you know that's baseball on one of those
home runs i think this was the only part
that it was going to be a home run in so
you can't really
fault it too much but um you know
there's going to be games where that
happens but uh
you know i might have jumped the gun a
little bit on you know making trying to
figure out wholesale changes and just
you know it's still early i'm playing
catch up pretty big right now of you
know i only had a couple starts last
year
and a couple of this year and obviously
i signed late so i'm still in the in the
catch-up mode and uh you know i really
noticed how much
execution is kind of the last thing that
comes after missing some time um you
know barely pitching at all so the stuff
i feel is there it's the execution
that's the issue so you know i can focus
on the execution pick better locations
make better pitches and you know maybe
that solves that problem right from the
get-go hey jake we appreciate the visit
man best of luck the rest of the way in
houston this year
all right appreciate it guys good
talking to y'all
the two out rbi single chases alex cobb
a pitching change enter alex claudio
we'll be right back
there you see right hander zach granky
on the mound
and a miss frankie picks up his first
strikeout
pull the string on him with the change
up and zach picks up back-to-back
strikeouts getting haggerty and henniger
breaking ball swing and a miss and
hagerty goes down on three pitches
another curve ball from grinke that's
his fourth strikeout
luis garcia up in the astros pin here's
the pitch
change up swinging a miss inside change
up and he gets him on three pitches and
there's one away here in the seventh
five strikeouts for grinke
[Music]
67 mile an hour curveballs that grencke
looking great tonight two outs into the
seventh
just toying with guys right now
flip that breaking ball out there
no chance marmillo's is going to be able
to stay back on that pitch
ground ball hits to the right side into
the shift to his right diaz he fields
throws to first eight shutout innings
for zach cranky
welcome back to the youtube game of the
week
back from minute maid park we are
presented by chime
with mark goobazza at angel stadium
jeff blum and brett dolan at minute maid
park matt baskersian and the angels go
to the bullpen early it's a little bit
of a dice roll here gooby as alex
claudio comes out
alex cobb did not have his a stuff as he
did 10 days ago however
he had gotten michael brantley out twice
tonight and it has kept him at a one for
12 for his career
there are two out here but the dice roll
is this because of the three batter
minimum if claudio
lets michael brantley get on base he's
got to face alex bregman this was a
calculated risk and
joe madden just felt like it was time
for alex cobb
and with claudio you always have a
chance with his change up to be able to
neutralize a right-handed bat so he's
thinking a sidearm breakable against
left here if he can't get him out he
still has a change up against brakeman
to get him out and i think because cobb
had not pitched in a while it was a
stressful amount of pitches this entire
game for him
a ball to strike to count to bradley
one for four against alex claudio in his
career again one for 12 against alex
cobb but cobb gone after 79 pitches
it was a two out double by martine
maldonado and then an rbi single by
carlos correa
and brantley lines that one into fair
territory and right
it'll be a ground rule double for
michael brantley
and that for the time being has
prevented a run
boy this is played right into dusty
baker's hands now
is this an automatic to walk alex
bregman here plummer
yeah it could be especially the way alex
is swinging the bat having some good
at-bats against alex cobb as you see
brantley just sneaking that one in that
right field line
unfortunately bouncing into the seats to
keep correa at third base
but i think to gooby's point with
claudio's change up he might throw a
couple off the plate and see if you
can't get alex bragging to roll one over
brantley the runner at second after his
sixth double of the year already
and the fire good and hot here owen won
the count to alex bregman
tell you what fellas i have not seen
this ball club in a long time swing it
like they are early
kind of the perfect storm right you've
got an astros team that couldn't wait to
get out of denver
then after all the coveted layoffs
guys that were inactive are healthier
you think he already made the point
jeff about bregman's legs looking fresh
and they catch alex cobb
on a night where he was 10 days between
starts
falling two strikes to count to alex
bregman
and there was a lot of conversation in
and around the houston area around the
houston astros
asking major league baseball why they
were playing and the minnesota twins
were not
astros having to call up four of players
from their alternate site to try and
fight through that road trip
but you're right these
couple of day layoffs will have effects
on guys both hitters and pitchers
bregman lines that into left field and
the whole thing is blown up two runs
will score and the astros take a
commanding six nothing lead
that absolutely backfired for the angels
[Music]
and you go back to the point with the
astros they're making contact i mean
these are not necessarily all squared up
baseballs tonight but they're putting
the ball in play that's towards the end
of the bat a changeup that was elevated
if it's down or to change up you can't
hit that ball in the air but because
it's elevated he's able to flare that
into the outfield so credit the astros
putting the ball in play and making
solid contact throughout
so here's your don alvarez now who's
been on base in both of his at-bats a
base hitting a walk each of those coming
against alex cobb
i mean this this is the the chance you
take knowing the three batter minimum
that if the move didn't make for the
first hitter and it didn't
then you got to face bregman who had big
numbers again against claudio
and now you got to get alvarez as well
a series of calculated risks
managing with the new rule
2-0 now
3-0
well what's helped the astros lineup
tonight certainly has been
the generous
base on ball
equivalent from the angels
three by alex cobb
statcast powered by google cloud every
time he sneezes it looks like a party
favor
jordan alvarez
spraying them all around the park
pretty impressive home run distribution
full count
and i believe
correct me if i'm wrong gooby his first
big league home run was up towards that
phillips 66 gas pump in left center
field i think it was dylan bundy
yeah i remember how far that went this
man is strong
and alex claudio minimizes the damage
if you can say such a thing at the end
of a three-run inning all astros tonight
at the end of three six nothing houston
so many people are so excited to see
these young men at 19 years old we
landed in l.a at like 6 30 quarter seven
and we take a cab
to anaheim which is an hour away right
russia
well here he is
center fielder mike trout his major
league debut tonight we had traffic to
get to anaheim we do not get to the
stadium
until the sixth or seventh inning
and we like running so listen here's the
other here's the killer so we tell them
mom says mike now leave us four tickets
we'll be there well i'd go up to the
poor kid he's i know he's got he's gone
he doesn't leave his tickets right we're
like okay just we'll buy tickets just
give us a ticket somewhere
and we finally get into the stadium it's
like the top of the eighth inning
and a ball is hit the center
this one that's right center and we had
just sat down mike trout giving chase
long run by trout he
runs it down
mike made that unbelievable catch out in
the outfield holy smokes what a catch by
the kid
[Applause]
welcome back to the mlb game of the week
on youtube presented by chimes six
nothing astros mike trout leads off the
fourth and he's wearing a microphone for
us tonight
where all these pitches are it's exactly
where i had them
and i checked off this one nice
mike will lead things off here in the
fourth inning he and the angels down by
six
all over the angels all-time career
leader board the only thing he does not
have a shot at is uh
sean figgins career caught stealing
record
the only one out of room oh yeah
yeah he hasn't been running as much but
he picks his spots while sean figgis the
old thing he's getting figgy with it
with figgins
who wants it for the cycle for the
angels which mike trout did as well
0-1 the count to mike you walked with
two out in the first that's one of only
two base runners against christian
javier and on another night plummer when
the astros haven't erupted for six in
three innings we'd be talking about
javier as being the story he's one of
the stories tonight in the midst of a
terrific starting performance having
struck out eight
yeah it's pretty amazing the ashers have
six runs on the board and it still
doesn't match up to those eight
strikeouts that javier has
and he's not a guy that's been known for
the swing and misability
usually he creates soft contact and uses
that defense behind him but he has been
a one-man show on top of that bump
tonight
three balls in a strike to count to
trout
mike trout through his walk tonight has
had 70 played appearances to start the
year he's been on base in 36 of them
and it's a full count to him now
you know what i don't understand gooby
and you've watched mike trout throughout
his career i don't understand
why he doesn't get the bryce harper
treatment more often that is to say
nothing to hit
well early he did with anthony brendon
in the lineup matt he got a lot more
fastballs last year that's why he saw
the home run with 17 home runs last year
oh man he got hit in the elbow and i
don't know that that got there's no pad
there i don't think
oh
all right he has a little protection
there right around the tricep barry but
that looked like he got it right in the
elbow
i tell you what even with those elbow
pads and that protection if you get
squared up on the elbow it is going to
hurt no matter what and that ball got
him good
it it did get him on the pad but blummer
to your point
it still hurts man that's a big strong
dude he doesn't react like that unless
it really hurts
understandable concern by the angels
almost looked as if he left that elbow
out there a little bit longer maybe not
anticipating that ball staying inside as
much as it was
yeah it almost as if he was not
concerned about getting hit with the
pitch on that one the way he stuck his
elbow out there
yeah i agree with you gooby
[Applause]
definitely didn't sound good no
he's going to try to stick around at
least for the time being and
i'm just
being informed
that tonight's home plate umpire ron
culpa you guys remember that mets
marlins game earlier that ended on the
hit by pitch play
that was controversial a lot of people
felt like michael conforto leaned into
it some people felt like the ball never
hit him at all
ron culpa had the plate for that one as
well
weird plays are following ron around mia
culpa
here's jared walsh now with the lead off
hitter abort
walsh one of the strikeout victims
first time through by javier seven of
the nine angels that stepped to the
plate struck out against him first time
around
it still looked like trout leaned in on
it was a game earlier this year where
walsh got hit by a pitch he goes that's
good for my on base percentage but trout
he's already got a high on base
percentage he doesn't need any more with
a hit by pitch
no he definitely doesn't and the league
doesn't want to see that guy get hurt
either
he's a lot of fun to watch when he's on
that ball field
oh and two to jared walsh
protect mode
well you know when you think about the
guys that have the mega deals and the
guys that have the
the biggest overall contracts
in baseball trouts being the biggest and
it's a group that includes
lindor betts tatis
padres fans were worried about the same
thing with their all-world shortstop
when the shoulder injury occurred
i mean there's just too much money
invested
too much hope in one player to have
somebody like that go down
remember the other day mookie betts same
thing got hit in the elbow area on a
pitch running in on him as well
they're like quarterbacks in the nfl
right when one of these all-world
talents a contract comes due
they jump to the front of the line i
don't know that anybody's going to get
past trout's 426 anytime soon though
that's a firm
number
yeah those kinds of numbers will make
your portfolio strong to quite strong
back to two balls and two strikes on
jared wall she started oh and two
battling here to even up the count up to
next
houston on top six nothing here in the
top half of the fourth
and walsh lines the ball back up the
middle
trout aboard after being hit by the
pitch let's listen into what it sounded
like in some of the reactions a little
while ago
[Applause]
right here yeah
anything right here
you wrote in and out
yeah
okay
okay to stick it out runners at first
and second to start the ending now for
justin upton trying to convert on a
five-game hitting streak
gooby what were those numbers you had
earlier javier second time through the
lineup
yeah 462 batting average against him
that second time through so there's an
opportunity for the angels to get back
but i'll tell you what his slider has
been so good tonight it's not gonna be
an easy task getting back even though he
struggled second time through
upton also a strikeout victim tonight
and he's able to lay off to move the
count to 2-0
i know it sometimes sounds odd but when
you're a pitcher and you hit a batter
especially with a six to nothing lead it
can rattle you a little bit and that
seems to be the case this inning
for javier after hitting trout with that
pitch inside he gives up a base hit out
over the plate against walsh and now 2-0
count but just enough did win a home run
yesterday exit velocity of 117 miles an
hour
two balls and no strikes
oh
call on a slider two and one
brett dolan a guy in justin upton that's
been around hard to believe this is
already his fifth year as an angel
well it's hard to believe he was drafted
back in 2005 the number one pick overall
and guys this is a class that is a bit
of a baseball dinosaur there are four
t-rexes left on active major league
rosters from that 2005 class anybody
want to take a guess or guess is on the
four remaining guys other than upton
still active on big league rosters
um
you're going to give me time to to uh
google it
i will say uh
two others are in the top 11 picks of
that draft so three guys of the five
that are remaining were picked in the
top 11 overall back in 2005. i know it
wasn't exactly yesterday but
that class might not be around in
another couple of years
chase to high fastball so from
behind 2-0 to a strikeout for javier his
ninth of the game
well let's let's pay it off here
uh ryan zimmerman was the only guy that
i kind of thought was there
but yeah a lot of these guys
jay bruce just shut it down jacoby
ellsberry is not playing anymore
jed lowry resurgent with the a's this
year
oh what a class it's amazing
amazing that four of the first five
picks were non-pitchers here's albert
now
pujol is also a strikeout victim tonight
[Music]
that draft was so long ago that ryan
zimmerman was a draft pick of the
montreal expos wasn't he that's right
that's right
actually i'm i'm being corrected we were
all wrong he was the first ever pick by
the nats that was their inaugural season
but have a jed lowry what he's doing for
oakland
didn't do a whole lot for the new york
mets back with the a's and the aces keep
on winning
yeah that'd be a fun team to be on right
now
pujol swings and misses it gets away
from maldonado so free 90 feet for trout
and walsh
and that'll get the angels out of a
traditional double play threat
it is not too often that you get albert
pujols to swing at a slider like that
that's one pitch he's had a tough time
with as a slider so far of the shierdo
plumber he's chased quite a few of them
early in the season
two and two
you know when you look at albert on the
other side
sorry go ahead blummer
no i was just gonna mention that's a
that's a sign of a veteran at bat right
there by albert pujols taking a wild
swing at a slider and then backing off
the next one because javier trying to go
back out there to get the chase
two balls and two strikes runners at
second and third six nothing houston
and albert pops that one up behind the
plate maldonado chasing and running out
of room
new to the mlb game of the week for the
2021 season is the youtube player of the
game where fans watching on mobile
devices and computers can vote for which
player will receive a trophy during the
post game show stay tuned for the player
of the game polling options coming up a
little later on
i don't think it's a stretch to say
christian javier is an early leading
candidate
albert looking for a base hit that would
get the angels on the board here in the
fourth
full count now
amazing thing about albert he's so in
tune on how they get a run home and i
know a lot of people talk about an rbi
not being the tell-all statistic of all
time but albert with over 2100 rbi
finds a way to get a run home no matter
what the scenario
three balls and two strikes runners at
second and third
one gone in the fourth
javier sitting on nine strikeouts
who pops this one up
[Applause]
two gone
nine strikeouts let's take a look at the
location of these pitches gooby on
statcast 3d powered by google cloud
well he's got the strikeout to the upper
third like we said and he's got some
nasty stuff but also with that slider
and curveball with great spin rate lower
part but upper part of the strike zone
impossible to read even though it's not
98 it's 92-94 with pretty good spin rate
as well upstairs
jose iglesias one of the victims tonight
the only angels that haven't struck out
are trout and rojas iglesias takes a
strike
this has been a game of deep
come
counts
alex com struck out four javier struck
out nine
they've been four walks tonight
two hit batsman
and it's owen two
[Applause]
well i'll tell you what he gets some
nasty spin rate his average spin rate on
the slider this year 25-21
major league average 24-26 well above
the major league average on spin on his
slider
in the air out to right
routine fly ball for kyle tucker to
retire the side nothing comes up runners
at second and third with one away
four impressive shutout innings for
christian javier
[Music]
being able to celebrate you know a birth
of our child
around his birthday it definitely means
a lot to all of us and you know we're
extremely excited erin cox was mike
trout's best friend
and jess trout's younger brother he was
born in august of 1994.
he died in august two years ago the
semicolon being a
symbol of suicide prevention they
started a suicide prevention campaign
called your game isn't over yet the
trouts worked with tiny turnip on a
powerful design that includes words of
encouragement in the stitches of the
baseball it's just something that's
really special to us that we were able
to do this in his honor and his name and
hopefully
make a difference and help another
family
from having to go through the tragedy
that we went through and there's one
more thing the trouts decided to do in
aaron's name
they gave it to beckham
beckham aaron
trout
hey each week this season on our
broadcast will focus on a youtube
content creator featured in our live
game commentary section today our
creator spotlight shines on matt
antonelli a member of the red sox
faithful matt's channel features
baseball tips
drills and instructions for players of
all ages search antonelli baseball on
youtube for more
remember matt from his
san diego padres days
padres getting ready to start a big four
game series in los angeles tonight and
here on youtube the astros off to a
commanding start tonight on top of the
angel six nothing back with jeff plum
mark good on brett dolden matt
vasquerian
and alex claudia will continue
he'll face julie guriel kyle tucker and
led miss diaz in the houston fourth
plummer i remember when aj hinch was
managing the astros and talking to him
about the kind of hitter that yulie
guriel is
hinch used to discuss
certain hitters for whom you give the
additional layer of information
metrics etc and certain guys who you
just give a little information too and
then let him go rake
he put guriel squarely in that second
category
yeah it's actually a really good call
and what a lot of fans don't know is
that julie curiel was a veteran playing
in cuba for years
so when he came into the major leagues
with the houston astros he was put a
little long in the tooth as far as
knowledge and how to play the game and
having a swing that developed in cuba
and he came over here and he was a gap
to gap type guy he knew which pitches he
could handle so i think it's kind of a
credit to aj hinch putting trust in
julie guriel to go out there and produce
and let him be who he is and it turned
out to be a pretty good move
hey kyle tucker has just beaten the
shift a little doinker up over the mound
this has got to be a game that's driving
gooby nuts being an ex pitcher and just
watching the astros dink and doing can
just continue to put runners on base
because they haven't hit the ball all
that hard in this game
yeah the dugout in the clubhouse may be
in jeopardy after i walked off the mound
at some point tonight
alex claudio being removed second
pitching change tonight for the angels
and we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
robert is safe at third louise swipes
bit of a risk with two outs but if
they're gonna give it to you take it
just bounce away here he comes 88's
coming home and the sox have the first
run of the 2021 season he lost his chain
he lost a little a little bit of gold
while he was charging home down the
third base line
[Music]
yellix in the right center
way back
off kepler kepler was there
defensively here in this ninth inning
bryce harper had some shoes uh to
display during introductions earlier
today
that is great
i think freddie was disappointed when it
didn't come out where they actually had
spikes on the bottom they did they did
[Music]
junior gary is on and a pitching change
and before we get to him a little bit of
a little bit of an opportunity to learn
more about kyle tucker on our chime
player spotlight
nicknamed ted
back in his rookie season because
somebody said he swung it like ted
williams no big deal there blummer no no
big comp no big shoes to fill in just
ted williams
i know when he was coming up we called
him teddy tucker
after teddy ball game but he came with a
pretty high prospect tag put on him and
if you remember during the jeff luno era
here in houston he was a highly coveted
player by other teams but they did not
want to let him go and he's finally
getting his opportunity in the big
leagues now
he's aboard after the one-out single and
he's running throw down his second
trickles through and tucker wisely
decides to stay at second base
his first bag of the year and it didn't
take him long to run against the new
angel pitcher right-hander javi guerra
right-hander junior guerra beg your
pardon
[Applause]
yeah i think to gooby's point they may
have keyed on that that's why he was
going so early in this count to make
sure he got into scoring position for
diaz
and garrus
1-0 pitches in for a strike
just the fifth stolen base for the
astros as a team this year
guerra making his sixth appearance of
the season
he has been effective
in albeit limited duty
first runs of the season didn't come
until
his uh last outing
his only outing on the last home stand
and that was control problems had some
walks in there fastball's pretty good
he's 91 to 95. he's got a curveball but
he's got a great split finger fastball
he throws a lot
following two strikes to count to lead
mustangs
throw the hands at it on the ground
iglesias to third not in time
rolling the dice there
jose thought he had enough time to get
the lead runner but it wasn't the case
and everybody's safe
and not worth taking another look at
there's not a lot of experience for jose
rojas at third base as well so a lot of
times in the third baseman if you have
maybe anthony brendon and veteran
they're gonna be closest to the bag
places anticipate he saw that guy tucker
trying to go makes a quick throw to be
able to slide in and get the inside part
of the bag and avoid the tag now more
pressure for the astros
mile straw had a big triple that drove
and run back in the second
the first of two three-run innings
against alex cobb tonight that
eventually would drive him from the game
in the bottom half of the third
owen won the count to mile straw
[Music]
blummer who is the fastest guy you ever
played with
oh man
i was on a ball club with dave roberts
he was pretty quick
we got a center fielder mike cameron who
i thought could absolutely
covered a lot of ground in center field
that's a great question michael bourne
oh michael bourne very fast on the
ground hot shot for rojas recovers and
gets diaz at second
but scoring easily from third is kyle
tucker and it's 7-0 houston
[Music]
never easy to turn a double play with
miles straw running but that had a at
least a bit of a shot if jose rose is
able to get that cleanly and get it over
the fletcher who's got tremendous as far
as getting rid of the baseball on the
transfer at second base
so now martine maldonado two rbis for
miles straw tonight
i think that would have been and
circling back to our earlier discussion
on you know dusty baker's lineup
construction we'll have to table this
as it looks like that pop is going to
end the inning yeah we'll talk about the
astros lineup as we continue but houston
strikes for one more
courtesy of miles straw once again and
to four seven nothing astros
[Music]
gorgeous evening for baseball here at
mid-may park the astros opening day
and it's 6-1 st louis astros have lost
seven in a row lowest scoring team in
major league baseball 15 and 30 is an
ugly start and that's a big hill to
overcome
[Applause]
this game tied 6-6 in the bottom of the
18th inning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this ballpark is just ready to erupt
they're down a run
one went away
[Applause]
you know every single guy in our ball
club says this is the way it's supposed
to be
that game is gone let's get on to the
next game
they're down to an out
fly ball in the right field and the
houston astros are going to the world
series for the first time in franchise
history
[Music]
seven nothing astros as we hit the top
half of the fifth inning let's uh pay
off our poll question from earlier we
asked which free agent shortstop is
going to get the biggest deal this
winter or whenever and 40 of you say
corey seeker
and i kind of
think that's true
hey blummer
fill us in on some of the conversation
in houston around the
six for 120 that carlos correa said not
even close to that the astros offered
recently
yeah i don't think he appreciated that
and you know if you actually break down
some of the numbers you can understand
why he didn't appreciate that i think he
wanted to get a little bit closer to
what francisco lendore was getting his
puerto rican friend
and he wants to believe that he can go
out there and be one of the more
dominant shortstops i think the only
knock if you had one against carlos
correa was how often is he going to be
on the field he averages just over a
hundred games
played per season since coming into the
big leagues and another thing you got to
remember about carlos correa is if he's
on the field he's going to he's going
gonna give you the best effort as far as
defense and offense but don't forget his
postseason numbers as often as the
astros have been in the postseason he's
he's going up on some of those historic
ladders and getting barking his name in
some of those history books in the
playoffs
jose rojas leads things off in the
angels fifth yeah i think you hit on the
big point there because the brighter the
lights the bigger the stage the better
that guy gets
and it's
kind of hard to quantify that right
worth we're a business that's made of
regular season numbers there's a base
hit for rojas his second of the game
i do agree with you that the uh you know
six years at 120 million for correa when
you consider the money that
other guys are making
most notably lindor and what seeger's
gonna get what story's gonna get
that's not gonna get it done it ain't
close and if it means carlos correa has
to pack his bags and go someplace else
it sounds like he's prepared to do that
the guy that i'd be concerned with is
javi baez at this point because
he had a really uneven
2020 off to kind of an uneven start this
year and in a contract year you hope
that that that's not in his head because
he is such an electrifying performer
well he's one of the best at his
defensive position you talk about a
quick tag at second base and incredible
power but when i'm looking at those
shortstop guys
seeger corey seeger is incredible i mean
he hits the ball so hard to all fields
mvp of the world series i mean he's only
getting better he's staying healthier so
corey seeger there and trevor story one
of the best base runners in the game the
shortstop with great power with colorado
the ball into strike accounts kurt
suzuki who struck out culminating a 13
pitch at bat back in the third
[Music]
now we had a chance to see
trevor story out there in colorado
colorado just recently i was surprised
to see that he did not have a home run
yet this far in the season so kind of
plays into that javier baez kind of mix
where they're off to that slow start but
i would imagine that all of these guys
are going to be grateful to have a 162
game season to be able to correct some
of those things and put up big numbers
to go get paid
good sliders swung out and missed once
again we've been saying that all night
yeah you know the one guy who whose
timing was the poorest as far as that's
concerned and he had no way of
controlling it was marcus simeon right
he his contract he came due
to the year after covet last year
and he got the one-year 18 million deal
to go to toronto and place second base
he'll be back on the market again at the
end of this season
two and two
and to your point mac marcus simeone i
saw him a number of times against the
angels
really good power fastballs in turned
into a really really solid defensive
shortstop working a lot with ron
washington when he was there with the
a's and he's a very good shortstop he
runs well with good power so for me he's
still going to get paid a lot of money
going into the offseason even though
there's some great short stops to go
along with him
yeah i agree with you even though he's
the oldest of the group i think there's
a multi-year deal out there a big one
for him as well
2-2 to suzuki hitting the air out to
left field and hit pretty well
room in time however for straw
and that's the first down of the inning
lumber you know one of the early kind of
pseudo-criticisms on christian javier
was
strikeouts and fly balls right doesn't
make them hit it on the ground as much
as they'd like
hasn't really mattered tonight because
the fly balls have been
warning track variety
and he's racked up a near double-digit
strikeout total so who cares if he's
giving up fly balls
yeah you can definitely say that tonight
but he's done a good job with that
fastball up the slider has really been
that one that
we have been talking about all game long
it's created the swing and miss you've
seen a couple called for strikes he's
gotten chase off the plate it's just
amazing to me to see that slider spin in
the
not necessarily on the edges but catch a
little bit more of the plate than you
would like to see and he still gets the
swing and miss
or he gets them just yanked just foul
thankfully
well among the nine strikeouts tonight
he has
twice victimized david fletcher who is
one of the hardest players to strike out
in all the baseball
one out one on astros on top seven
nothing that's bounced up the middle
backhanded by diaz to correa they get
the out at second base
a fine play up the middle
[Applause]
yeah wide decision by gray to get right
to the bag as he has to be able to get
the coverage he's on the shortstop side
of the bag a quick flip and gets
rojas just barely at second base
outstanding defensive play the astros
one of the better defensive teams over
the last number of seasons a couple of a
big play here within any kind of a rally
getting started here with the ground
ball out javier loving that defense
there's that ground ball that mattie
wanted
is that his first ground ball out
tonight
it is
yes yes
and here's otani now who has flied to
center and struck out
shohei bounces it right to guriel
nothing comes of the lead off single
christian javier
a career-high workload
and enroute to a career-type night on
top 7-0
[Music]
he
just smokes it
[Music]
[Applause]
strike three
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
something like this is what they came
for
[Applause]
this copyrighted telecast is presented
by authority the office of the
commissioner and may not be reproduced
or re-transmitted in any form the
accounts and descriptions of this game
may not be disseminated without express
written consent
adding to this unique viewing experience
don't forget to check out youtube's live
game commentary featuring mlb the angels
the astros and a select group of youtube
creators you can view the live game
commentary on your computer mobile
device or smart tv
we'll be keeping an eye on the
discussion throughout the broadcast be
clever
there's a chance we'll use your comments
on the show
mike trout has come out of the ball game
after being hit in the elbow a couple of
innings ago tried to stick around scott
shebler has taken over in center field
for him
and if we get word from the trainer's
table we'll certainly pass it along
we'll assume that mike's been taken out
of the ballgame as a precaution
in a seven nothing day
i think we all understand that
carlos correa leads things off in the
houston half of ending number five top
of the order correa brantley and bregman
the angels have had to go to that
alternate site travel taxi quite often
already this year
schedler had a really nice spring
training with the angels
and there were a lot of people that
thought he had a puncher's chance to
make the opening day squad right out of
camp
and as it turns out he was pressed into
duty this week because of a flurry of
injuries hey look out
three and one to correa
full count three and two to correa
it's taken me a couple innings to notice
this but carlos correa has gone to a
decided fashion statement at the plate
sends a breaking ball into left for
another base hit
third of the game
he's aboard mike trout's out of the game
uh but mike trout's mike picked up this
before mike exited the occasion
i see you talking about the new map
yeah yeah i haven't played it tonight
yeah
i thought it was a slider dude oh really
dude i can't pick up the ball here
though
this stuff is this stuff looks like that
too i faced him obviously yeah
if i have a pad bro
is he talking about if he had a pad if
he had a pad on his elbow
[Applause]
if he
didn't have the pad on that elbow ah
got it got it got it yeah that's what it
was yeah
yeah
when you look at his numbers he doesn't
hit the ball real well here in this
ballpark and he's about a 218 career
hitter
in minute may park so there is some
validity the fact that he doesn't see
the ball real well because everywhere
else trout has hit the ball well well
your reaction when he was hit by that
pitch gooby was that you even said at
the time it looked like mike didn't
think that the ball was going to come in
on him like that
which again would back up the statement
yeah like he was reading he was thinking
slider
it was ready to track it out over the
plate
and you know that got him pretty good
without that that pad on his elbow area
he would be in trouble on that one
here's alex bregman now he's been on
base in all three of his plate
appearances tonight two singles
and he was hit by a pitch in the second
add another base hit man he and correa
are going nuts at the top of this order
carlos is going to score
and the astros are on the board again
[Music]
astro's doing a good job of just
fighting off some of these pitches again
the exit velocity is not going to light
up any radar gun but the fact that
they're getting these hits with runners
in scoring position
means everything to them right now
yeah i was just going to say the same
thing the exit velocity radar gun was
not going to be real high here tonight
but you look up you got eight runs
that's all that matters
look at that alex bregman has already
matched his three-hit total from all of
last year now it's big jordan alvarez
fires still hot as they say
one out one on and one in
hey blummer i want to get back to uh
to what mike trout was talking about
look you played here for many years you
have broadcast here for many years why
for a visiting player might it be harder
than someplace else to pick up the ball
well i'm glad you brought the fact that
i did play here when i did play here
they had towels hill out in center field
they had that little bit of a ramp up of
a hill in center field about
430 feet away and the batting eye was a
little bit bigger but back in
2016-17 they altered that took away the
hill brought in the batting eye and kind
of they didn't really condense it but
it's just not as big as it was in the
past
and they also added led lighting it
really brightened things up in this
ballpark and early on a lot of the home
ball players the astros most notably had
issues picking up spin because the led
was so bright on that baseball it was
tough to pick up the seams
wow when did the led go in here
i believe it was around eight sets 17 18
19 was when they were starting to make
these adjustments but the leds came in
and what's different about other
ballparks here at minimate park is that
they don't have that expansive outfield
that the bleachers aren't exactly all
that high
so the lights are a little bit closer to
the field
alvarez sends one out to the scoreboard
and left it's handled by upton for route
number two
[Music]
the batters feel like it's easier to see
with the roof closed or with the roof
open not that it's open a lot but in the
beginning of the year you have a chance
to have it open
yeah and here in houston if you have a
chance to leave any roof open and get
out of the freon zone of our houses and
dome stadiums they take advantage of it
but uh if you ask the players man man
for man they want to play with that roof
closed because they love the controlled
environment
here's guriel now a couple of walks for
him one coming with the bases loaded
i i think as fans we like to uh kind of
read all the scandal theories into the
conditions
roof open
roof closed we all bought into it in
arizona for many years when schilling
and johnson were there and
kurt schilling always wanted the roof
closed when he started so everybody kind
of jumped on that as a scandal theory
guriel sends a fly ball out to shallow
right fletcher tracking it to retire the
side not before one more can come home
for the astros we've played five
complete
all houston
at minute maid tonight
[Music]
has to feel great about his ball club
right now they can put a banner right up
next to that 1980 western division
championship banner with a win this
afternoon ball two and strike one to
maldonado and he popped him up nothing
doing top half of the first inning here
at the astrodome here's that 2-2 pitch
hey got him that's the third fish guy
swinging a miss
three up and three down as we're in the
middle of the fourth inning at the
astrodome no balls and two strikes
listen to the crowd they're in on it now
they know what's going on
he got in
strike three mike scott has struck out
the side what a game mike scott is
throwing on clincher day
that'll do it no hitter going here for
mike scott
fly ball to left center field and scott
still has the no hitter going he has it
going through eight innings oh boy what
drama gene
two outs
nobody on
top of the night scott has not given up
a hit
there it is
new to the mlb game of the week for the
2021 season the youtube player of the
game fans watching on mobile devices and
computers can vote for which player will
receive a trophy during the post game
show stay tuned for the player of the
game holding options
coming up a little bit later on
yeah i would suggest carlos correa
let's see who else would i suggest
christian javier for sure michael
brantley's had a nice night bregman a
lot of options on a night that has been
pretty much a houston story tonight at
minutemate park
and the astros go to the bullpen
a career-high pitch count and a
career-high strikeout tally for the
young 24 year old starter christian
javier he's gone after five in favor of
brian abreu
scott schedler the first to face him
schedler batting in trout spot in the
order
came on after mike was hitting the elbow
by a pitch back in the fourth so
shoveler walsh and upton for the angels
hey matt what about putting dusty baker
in his player of the game for putting
carlos correa at the lead-off spot for
the first time in his career i like that
idea that's a great idea that is a great
yeah it is
do we get to visit with the player of
the game tonight because if we do yeah
i'd vote for dusty just because i love
talking to the guy
two balls and two strikes to count to
scott shevler who we talked about
earlier is having a really good spring
training for the angels
but when the decisions were made who to
break camp with juan lagar has got a nod
in the outfield because of his defensive
prowess
and schedler's worked it to a full count
three balls and two strikes
yeah that was an issue last year
defensively in the outfield you bring in
a gold glove or four gold glover with
the new york mets and juan lagardes
that's why he was so he had a really
solid spring swing in the back but his
defense was the difference maker
it was also unfortunate news about
dexter fowler too gooby
yeah they expected him to be the switch
hitter
solid defender in the outfield be the
everyday guy on occasion give juan
lagardes everyone a chance in the
outfield to give a rest because he could
play all three outfield positions so
well
caught looking at a called strike three
brett dolan has a little bit more on the
former red and dodger scott shepler
guys he told the media that he's been
playing basically without a shoulder for
the last couple of years the doctor went
in and found out that there was probably
a significant tear going back to 2017 it
hurt to pick up the bat i can't imagine
how he played through that for a couple
of years it must have been a mess but as
an iowa native i can appreciate that
toughness there aren't many guys by the
way that come out of dmacc des moines
area community college to find their way
to the major league shoulder or not
you corn fed iowa guys man you all find
each other
this and if he hurt his shoulder in 2017
that's the year he hit 30 big boys i
mean he had a great year in cincinnati
that season to chopper on the ground to
first
and brayu covers for out number two
so two gone for the reliever of brayu
and he'll go to work on justin upton now
this has been all astros kind of from
the jump three in the second three more
in the third lone runs in the fourth and
fifth
christian javier was outstanding on the
mound
and here's up to now
this has not been a very kind place for
the angels in general you know we talked
about it as it related to mike trout
and as much as the angels finally won a
season series from the astros last year
it's something that hasn't happened very
often
they entered play tonight having
dropped 14 of their last 17 games in
this ballpark that dates back to 2018.
a lot of that is that the astros have
been very good over that stretch
but this has not been a very kind place
to the angels when they come visit
and i really think it comes down to the
way they were able to have their
pitchers and they've had a great
pitching staff over the years running a
lot of those four-seam fastballs upper
part of the strike zone and a lot of
angels hitters use that lower third and
that's where they do the damage
that's a lot of credit to pitching coach
for the astros brent strom
he's kind of created an a whole nother
legacy with what he's been able to do
with pitchers here at minimate park but
it started with him in the philosophy of
throwing that forcing fastball up in the
zone
and what that did is it got some swing
and miss it got some pop-ups but at the
same time it opened up the bottom part
of the zone for some of these high-spin
breaking ball type guys that they've
tried to get here in houston
yeah he's a good one plumber and you you
have the uh the pleasure of getting to
tap his brain daily
uh he is not a guy that goes out there
and digs himself and talks about his
philosophy he's a grinder man and he's
made so many pitchers better
coming to houston
that i think the results speak for
themselves he doesn't have to pump
himself up
and very true what you said about him
being a grinder he you know he's been in
the game a very long time and then moved
here to houston to become the pitching
coach
and really embraced the analytics and
found a way to marry that with his eyes
and his experience to make these guys
that much better
you know i've heard him talk about you
know adjusting guys sliders to a quarter
of an inch of release
and you know extension through the zone
and things like that so he's really
adapted to this current game and made
his knowledge that much more valuable
going to the count to albert pools
and had it not been for tommy john as a
story i know that astros fans have heard
many times
that
ucl ligament replacement surgery would
have been known as brent strom surgery
because he was the second guy to have it
after tommy john did
still owing to you i think it's kind of
interesting
it's kind of interesting you know bring
up that point because we have talked
about it a lot and brent strom
kind of makes fun of it also knowing
that he was the second one to get that
tommy john surgery but he always says
imagine if they didn't call it tj
surgery and i was the first one to get
it
yeah that's a good point it all worked
out for a reason
yeah
yeah
i'm going in for my bs surgery yeah it
doesn't
not the hurt gravitas i got my tj
[Laughter]
san diego guy i'd imagine that brent
strom was watching with interest when
joe musgrove finally pitched the padres
first ever no-hitter a couple of weeks
ago in arlington
the 1-2 to pujols
yeah joe musgrove has a connection
coming up through the astros
organization eventually being traded
away but it meant a lot to astro fans to
watch joe musgrove do that but for you
and i maddie having experience both
being padres in our career i was i was
in shock and just pure joy watching him
do it for the franchise you bet such a
great story for local guy
pujols to right field that's got a
chance if it stays fair and that one's
gone
[Applause]
albert pujols to the opposite field to
get the angels on the board in the sixth
boy you look over the last number of
seasons how many home runs has albert
hit that way
665
career home runs for albert 61 now in
his career versus the astros
for the machine
yeah this this is not a foreign site for
fans here at minimade park
pitch up and away and he goes with it
i'm not too sure boys wait a minute wait
a minute this one yeah plumber i'm with
you all boundary calls are reviewable
oh boy that's a foul ball
yeah you can see the baseball
into white going about a yellow pole
i think the only thing that
that might make this call stand is if
they can determine that the ball
actually touched
the pole
me it looked like it missed it
we'll give you plenty of looks here at
home on youtube
i don't think you can tell if it hit the
pole or not guys
see albert back there can you see albert
in the back room
he said hit the fall
call on the field was homer
albert's still looking max stats he
knows this ballpark really well he says
yeah it did
max stashy back there yep
yep i said yeah i know this ballpark
really well
albert's saying what matt you have been
you've been involved in some interesting
replay reviews throughout the course of
the season already this year yeah yes
this is true
nothing will expose an overexposed
play-by-play guy like controversial
replay reviews let me tell you
i just can't tell if it hit the pole or
not guys
i i don't think anybody can tell based
on this
and if the call is really tough the call
in the field is homer like
how do you over
man this is a tough one
yeah and that's the biggest key matt is
the call on the field is what's being
sent back to new york and is there
anything to overturn that
albert's saying man don't take this
would be my first opposite field homer
in two years don't take it away
yeah it's gonna stand he knew it
[Laughter]
park a lot
[Applause]
if albert pujols hits a ball that's
anywhere near an outfield fence in
minute maid park somebody is going to
definitely think it's a home run that's
for sure
climbing the all-time home run
leaderboard he's going to have to go
crazy in the final year of his 10-year
contract to catch alex rodriguez
as he trails him by 31.
somebody threw it back hey i think
albert might want that
he's still saying it deflected off the
foul pole
[Laughter]
0-1 the counts are hosting still trying
to sell it
yeah
all right we're going to give you some
some video tricks here to see if
anybody can tell if it hit the pole or
not
maybe it did man i don't know i just
can't tell
let's take a look at it again
sure looked like it did
yeah i mean we can't get too much
tighter on it
and
quite frankly it doesn't matter what we
think because the call stands
by the way did that baseball deflect off
the foul pole and deflected off a fan's
hand into another fan's hand as well so
that baseball had all kinds of stuff
deflection wise
that thing is greased
still on two to jose iglesias
and that's wrapped out to shortstop
correa's got it throw just barely gets
him but the angels do get on the board
third of the season for albert and his
first to the opposite field in two years
it's eight to two houston
a chance for the first one two three
inning of the night for young chase
wright if you can get manny ramirez here
in the third
well
that one is on its way and goodbye
over everything
onto the streets of boston it welded
deep right center field going back and
free you hear the red sox bullpen that
one's gone
back to back home runs ramirez and drew
and the sox are back within three to two
swung on there it goes to deep left that
one's headed for new hampshire
[Applause]
what a shot and they're playing home run
derby early this year at fenway park
three booming home runs in a row
[Applause]
cabrera won't even turn around but for
four in a row
four consecutive home runs
this one by jason varatek we're talking
record setting territory now the first
time in red sox history four home runs
in a row
[Music]
download the mlb app to get in-game
video highlights live pitch by pitch
breaking news player updates stat
leaderboards and much more
so we've had these poll questions all
night they've been a lot of fun uh
here's my favorite by the way who would
make the best road trip companion
from la to houston joe madden
nolan ryan
dusty baker or torrey hunter we just put
torrey in there
connections to both sides of course
that's a great question no wrong answer
there
eight to two houston
as junior guerra continues so get kyle
tucker led miss diaz and miles straw
back with mark gubazar in anaheim
and from houston
brett dolan and jeff blum matt
vasquezian here at mlb network
and we're all coming to you tonight on
youtube on this exclusive mlb telecast
[Music]
one and one the count to tucker who has
singled scored and stolen the base
tonight
by the way joe maddon has this thing
called an rv called the cousin eddie so
that might be a pretty fun little road
trip to go in his rv
from houston l.a
a ball in two strikes
i think what gooby is saying is that we
could all jump in there with joe madden
and have a great trip
what what he likes the music we all get
in joe's van and and dusty's riding
shotgun we get in the back and we just
listen to their stories
spray down to the left side of the
infield
and there's one gun to start the sixth
you know we asked both of the managers
the same question that we asked dylan
bundy when we visited with him earlier
what the last thing that they watched on
youtube as far as an instructional video
would go is how many times a day do you
find yourself trying to do something
unable to do said task and having to
youtube it
and for joe madden it was how to hit my
driver
and dusty's was much more interesting i
thought
how to plant and grow
texas onions in california
that is everything you need to know
about dusty right there
renaissance man
two balls are no strikes to count to led
miss diaz
you think about the baseball that that
guy has been witness to
in his career
the career itself what he had to endure
in the minors
being
in the marine corps during his playing
career there's a base hit
diaz has done that a couple times
tonight
and that's his third of the evening
there were four angels surrounding that
baseball and not one of them could get
to it that is how it's going for the
astros tonight
yeah joe biden was talking a lot about
his golf game i'll tell you what the
astros have brought out the sand wedge
really well tonight worked the club in
there phil mickelson would be happy with
this action on the sandwich today
i mean they're bringing back the old
school pilato ball for this game
this is not one of those nights where
the
collective exit velocity the astros is
going to impress you but they do lead by
six in the bottom of the sixth inning
and now it's miles straw who's had a
nice night
drove in a run with a triple in the
second and drove in another on a
fielder's choice play in the fourth
boy today was like a youtube except you
know instructional video from david
fletcher how to get base hits without
exit velocity for the astros yeah
right just when you just when you think
you need to square up a ball and barrel
it if we may borrow the statcast term to
do damage
tonight is proof of the contrary
the astros biggest
hit-and-run total since the first week
of the season
and it comes at a time when it is most
needed just to revisit what we talked
about earlier tonight blummer having
lost nine of ten
really rough road trip through seattle
and denver
and home cooking is tasting really good
tonight
yeah i completely whipped on the idea of
them having to score runs with the home
run ball but it's been the hitting with
runners in scoring position that's done
them
very well tonight going 4 for 10 in this
game so far
and even going 4 for 10 they've left 9
runners on
two balls and two strikes to count to
mile straw
on the ground to shortstop
no way you're gonna turn two with that
guy's speed and fletcher knew it didn't
even bother with a turn
so straws aboard with two gone
we were talking about martin maldonado's
contract extension a little bit earlier
and after a quick pitching change we're
gonna
revisit that topic i think joe has
already made the move
because ben rowan was up
and it looks like ben rowan is on his
way into the game
the pitching change with the man on and
two away in the last of the sixth we'll
be right back
not a lot of 20 year olds not only
perform well but perform well in every
aspect of the game that quickly
i don't think anybody including trout
thought he'd have the kind of year that
he had in 2012. it was a season with
almost too many mike trout highlights to
count but there was one signature moment
that came to define his gifts more
famously than any other
this looks at the center field indeed
back out at his trout back it goes it
[Applause]
is takes a home run away
what a play by the 20 year old in center
field and you bet he's smiling that was
an unbelievable play
that catch that he made in baltimore i
was almost passed out because of the
adrenaline that was in me just watching
him jump up and reach over that wall
might try with another spectacular grab
it was one of the greatest catches i've
seen with my eyes i've made some and
people say oh toriel was awesome catch
but i hadn't i didn't see it you know
just watching it it was the greatest
vision i've ever had
all season long major league baseball
will honor frontline and essential
workers who continue to lift up their
fellow citizens during the pandemic
thank you frontline heroes
kova 19 vaccinations are safe and
effective join the team and get the
vaccine to help us all get back to doing
what we love together visit
mlb.com19 resources for more information
two out pitching change with a man on
and an eight to two astros lead
as joe madden has opted for right-hander
ben rowan
yeah expect a slider from ben rowan he
throws about 75 of his pitches slider
also through a little two-seam sinking
fastball
martine maldonado the batter as the
angels shade the left side of the
diamond
maldonado has
doubled and scored tonight
and rowan as so many relievers do
start with a check-in at first base
ben made his angels debut april 14th in
kansas city that was his first big
league appearance since 2016.
he has been a great
story of stick-to-itiveness
and the sidewinder is in for a strike
ben didn't get into any game action
during the recent home stand a lot of
that coming because part of it was
canceled that series with the twins
and it's owen one to martine maldonado
no stolen base credited there is miles
straw just advanced on defensive
indifference
i say give him the bag i don't believe
in defensive indifference
yeah it's still it's only a six run game
in the sixth inning i think that's a
stolen base yeah
that's how i would score it
a ball and a strike to count to martine
maldonado
wow rowan gets a call below the strike
zone
and maldonado sends a fly ball the other
way to right
jared walsh has it a couple of angels
combined on a scoreless bottom of the
sixth
getting to the back third
it's taken a while
and it's eight to two houston
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that deserves a wow that's over the 390
sign in left center
and first pitch crushing
oh man
lean into it here's a guy that throws
the ball 101 on one half of the inning
and the next one is the first pitch to
150 feet
man i mean that ball was crushed wow
that was ridiculous
and trout gets a hold of one into the
corner and left daddy got it
homer's in 10 straight two-run shot for
trout maddie i'm going with you to vegas
at some point great call now with this
kind of thing okay let's get that home
run streak going i mean everything going
to halo's way tonight
[Music]
google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
google cloud is the official cloud
technology of major league baseball
and with the help of statcast powered by
google cloud let's take a look at the
albert pujols homer
albeit a little controversial
slid past the fair pole it was a call
that was reviewed
and upheld
[Applause]
and albert was thrilled
yeah
665th of his career
anyone will probably go you know what
i'll take it
little foul pole scraper
carrying on like a guy who hadn't hit
one before right
giddy like a 19 year old rookie
jose rojas leaving things off for the
angels
that's really the lone bright spot for
the angels on this series opener because
the home side has really dominated from
the opening bell
three in the second three in the third
lone runs in the fourth and fifth
christian javier was outstanding
and it's up to brian abreu and company
here to hold the six run lead
three balls and no strikes to jose rojas
a great story grew up in the anaheim
area angel fan 36 round draft pick one
hit coming into the game two hits
tonight
yeah you know if if if you expand that
narrative a little bit gooby and talk
about
hits for a hometown kid
and of course born in anaheim high
school in anaheim for jose
and you start digging through the major
league record books wondering
who's the guy that had the most hits for
his hometown team
it just happens to be the guy with the
most hits
pete in cincinnati yeah pete in
cincinnati
strikeout for abreu his first
of the inning of course
but yeah all 3 358 for pete count
because he went to western hills high
school in cincinnati no i don't think
anybody's ever going to catch that
next up would be cal ripken
if you want to count aberdeen high
school in aberdeen maryland which is
about 40 minutes away from camden yards
granted it's not it's not the city
proper
here's kurt suzuki now
strikes the count to suzuki who's over
two tonight
hey yeah got him oh man
how many hit batsman tonight is that
three or four
trout in the elbow now suzuki in the
elbow bregman got hit in the elbow
dark got it
they're getting squared up run to the
point of that elbow too it's
not exactly an ideal situation but
that was a little bit of a slider that
never broke and ended up just spiraling
itself into the elbow of kurt suzuki
i'm not sure too sure those pads are
working
i know
did do everything right as far as
turning the body turning the head but
that elbow gets hit right on that pad
just like trout
reminds us that we do get word on mike
trout status and the angels are calling
it a left elbow contusion and as painful
as that word may be it's certainly
better than the alternative
and suzuki's aboard
hey why is it as we say hello to our
worldwide youtube audience once again
tonight
why is it that
padsers i get it like plastics
technology has improved dramatically but
when you know craig biggio and barry
bonds were up there padded up the stuff
looked like
it gave you a little bit more of a
chance
this stuff's very thin i go back to the
old school thing is what i'm saying
it didn't affect terry bonds at all i
know that way he got through the ball
yeah barry hanging that barry hanging
that thing out over the plate allowed
him to get to a lot of pitches you're
right but
between biggio and bagwell i know [ __ ]
i played with him here in houston and
you could take that elbow guard off of
his elbow and put it on somebody's shin
guard he could go back behind the plate
and catch with it that thing was healthy
we've got a visit to the mound it looks
like brent strom's coming out to chat
with uh with abreu
a quick chat it was and now david
fletcher digs in
i've often wondered why guys don't go
back to that and then again i'm the kind
of guy that stays up at night wondering
why the old bubble chest protector that
umpires used to use isn't back in vogue
because i love the fact that it allowed
them to get right up there
close and personal with the strike zone
by the way guys uh i hate to be able to
go out and reference this again but i
still have the whole time all-time
record for kansas city royals as far as
hit batters which so a lot of times
baseball just gets away from here do you
really you still got the record
yeah walks wild pitches and hit batters
all those really good things you want to
be at the top of the list with also
known as black ink right when you leave
something you lead in a category you get
a lot of black ink all you need to do is
tell people check my baseball reference
page there's a ton of black ink there
[Laughter]
counts a ball in two strikes
one out one on here top of the seventh
inning astros up by six two balls and
two strikes now to david fletcher
and by the way every one of those i was
just trying to establish the ball inside
that's all i was ever trying to do of
course
yes
the teeth of the angels lineup really
not making an impact tonight mike trout
has been removed from the game after
walking and being hit by a pitch
fletcher swats that one pass to diving
bregman into left
well exactly the scenario joe madden
wanted to have runners aboard for shohei
ohtani
who is off to a striking start
statcast powered by google cloud some of
the interesting numbers
top percentile in
average exit velo as a hitter
his average forcing fastball velocity
fifth best out of over a hundred players
and perhaps the most under-reported
aspect of his game gooby he is fast
incredibly fast
like the bond white type fast
looks like we're gonna have a chance to
talk more about him after a change
because
to the bullpen dusty baker goes for
brooks rayleigh and we'll be right back
[Music]
he
just smokes it
[Music]
[Applause]
that ball was crushed
strike three
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
something like this is what they came
for
[Applause]
[Music]
big opportunity for shohei otani who is
enjoying full health in
2021 had it not been for the injuries no
telling what he would have accomplished
already the ucl the ucl injury came up
in 2018 tommy john the left knee was a
problem on both sides of the scorecard
surgery to correct that forearm strain
last august shut him down on the bound
but ohtani is over all that markup is
and you are seeing him at the peak of
his powers this year
what he's thrown on the mount he puts
101 miles per hour exit velocity on a
home run 115.5 but his speed running
down the bases
is something that is truly remarkable
oh and one to count to ochani
could even go back to when he found out
he had had to have tommy john's surgery
talked to the doctor and said you're
going to have a tommy john's surgery
that night he went out and hit two home
runs
at the plate
in texas it was incredible to see
somebody to have that kind of focus the
hit home runs after no one you're gonna
have tommy john's surgery
and ohtani behind one two it is brooks
rayleigh in from the bullpen for the
astros
the lone left-hander in the bunch
kind of inflated numbers again short
sample size
fewer than seven innings
slider misses and it's a ball in two
strikes
yeah it's been those last couple of
outings for brooks rayleigh that have
gotten to him
giving up a couple of three earned runs
in his last two outings he's
heavy on that cut fastball pitched in
the kbo a couple of years ago
as a starter the astros brought him here
and told him to get on that cut fastball
and it's been effective for him when
he's been able to get on that outside
edge
trying to shoot that outside edge there
it's two balls and two strikes to otani
and you know what's been a lot of fun
watching ohtani is that we actually when
we used to be able to get on the field
he is a large human
i mean he is every bit of six foot four
he's got the build but when he takes off
and run runs like gooby's talking about
at 29 feet per second he makes it look
easy effortless
jam shot off the fists as it squibs out
to correa he wins the race to the bag
and that's the second out of the inning
ohtani homered yesterday for the fifth
time one of the four solo shots by the
angels and gooby what was more
impressive than this was the pace around
the base this was a home run trot
look at him yeah i was what i was
watching the game i broke it down like
he's pretty like adam rosales did when
he's going for a home run he's like all
right i want to get down there as quick
as possible i was laughing so hard how
quick he got around to bases
he doesn't want to suppress those stack
cast numbers
here's scott shevler now struck out on
his first try in the sixth inning
wait a minute now i'm now i'm thinking
you're serious plumber statcast numbers
don't take into account home run trot do
they
i don't think they do i'm not sure
i hope not
oh here we go
[Applause]
that's elite man
again it's your point it doesn't look
like it because he's a big man
yeah he got down the line right there at
twenty nine point six feet per second
[Applause]
two and one to show look bo jackson
on his first major league hit he had a
ground ball to second base going down
the line so that was the guy that i
would think is the fastest human being
i've ever seen in person i saw him on
the football field but on the baseball
field he could flat out fly beau
and if anybody wants to know when when
we used to travel to anaheim some of the
questions i'd ask you would be about
beau jackson and his abilities
on a hop perfectly placed for correa to
extinguish the threat
stretching in houston in an 8-2 astros
lead
[Applause]
this ball hit hard again michael
brantley home run for the third straight
opening day
every year as an astro michael brantley
has hit a home run uncle mike what other
teams are saying uncle on opening day
they're saying mike uncle
alex bregman on a 2-2 pitch
drives one deep to left field that
ball's gone
back-to-back jax bradley and pregnant
and the astros now lead 5-1 back-to-back
bangers
jordan sends one in the air to center
field well hit going all the way back to
the wall that ball is gone
the big man jordan alvarez hits one to
left center field a three-run shot and
the astros take a 5-1 lead
there we go we got liftoff that is not
an easy pitch to get and that's out on
the outside corner and jordan stays on
it steps on it and drives it
[Music]
check out the astros youtube page for
insider content including behind the
scenes takes from your favorite astros
players coaches
dry humor with steve sparks and more
visit youtube.com astros to subscribe to
the channel today
here are the results from the poll guys
i'm curious to see how this shook out
joe madden uh finishes second to nolan
ryan of course
wow
i didn't want to influence the vote but
dusty was my guy
i want to get in the car with dusty and
just have him talk that's it
by the way if you wanted to laugh
forever tory hunter by the time you got
to la from houston your ribs will be
killing you the stories of the way he
makes you laugh though
bummer is normal nolan ryan would be a
good one is he around a lot these days
uh he was you know his son reed ryan
used to be the president of the astros
he has since moved on but when reed was
around nolan was around a lot more also
and they've actually honored nolan ryan
a couple of times here in houston with
the houston sports award inducting him
dan pastorini and some other legends
here in houston into a hall of fame
locally
but nolan ryan is one of the greatest
conversations you could ever ask for
we've had him in the booth a couple of
times telling stories about those 1980s
astro teams that were competing in the
national league west and just hearing
that southern drawl talk about baseball
there's nothing more pure than that oh
yeah
i'd love to be a party to that for sure
balls in a strike account talking about
sorry matt
and nolan ryan talking about guys not
being able to get three times through a
batting order nolan ryan notorious for
going deep into ball games had a tough
time understanding how hard it was for
guys nowadays to get that third time
through the lineup
two balls and two strikes to count to
correa top of the order here for the
astros in their half of the seventh
carlos sends the ball the other way out
to right walsh at the track one gone
well you know gooby i'm curious we
haven't talked about this at length and
i'm curious about you know as somebody
who came up in a different era of
pitching and pitching pedagogy you guys
were taught how to do it differently
do you think that guys today
want to post up and go longer
and it's it's front offices that have
held them back and changed the training
or is it vice versa
i i think the players that pitchers
still want to do that i had a
conversation with gary cole a couple
years ago about that that whole third
time through stuff and he said once i
got through the first time through the
lineup i was in cruise control i didn't
care what they knew i was throwing as we
went forward i was going to be effective
and every guy on the uh dylan bundy if
you ever get anybody up when he's uh in
the sixth or seventh inning you better
be ready to run away from him as far as
the pitching coach and manager they want
to still be out there i know the numbers
you know it will tell you third time
through batting average goes up but they
kind of average that out with the fifth
starter as compared to the first starter
second start of rotation where you get
better as the game progresses
in my opinion
fall in two strikes to michael brantley
well of all of nolan ryan's records that
will never be broken
here's one that i would offer
is just iron clad for the rest of time
222 complete games
i mean by the way that's not the record
but that's nolan's number nobody's
come on
two complete games in a career seems
like a pipe dream now
that's incredible
two and two
by the way going back to the traveling
ryan across the country uh can you
imagine if he wasn't happy with you he
would robin venturi at some point i said
no no i don't want nolan in there just
in case he got mad at me
still two and two to brantley yeah i
i would hate to be
you know leaving from houston get to el
paso and all of a sudden we turn around
and see gooby in a headlock
[Laughter]
i'd be like gooby you're on your own man
plumber i thought you were my wingman
you were gonna let me go huh
hey man i've seen that dude do some
damage i'm not sure i want part of that
full count three balls and two strikes
to count to michael brantley
you mentioned bus trips to el paso i
just had a texas league flashback
working in the texas league and brantley
has a base hit
as we mentioned uh you know there was no
wrong answer in that full question who
do you want to take a road trip with
brett you've been around dusty for a
while now
give me your give me some of your best
dusty stuff
well guys i don't know if
people wanted to travel with dusty on
that road trip but if you need somebody
on that wall
dusty's your guy how about him telling
us today that five or six years during
his career he had to step away for two
weeks in season to do his marines duty
camp lejeune quantico pendleton and
there were no rehab assignments back
then so he had to come back after a
couple of weeks of not picking up a
baseball and he had to try and be
effective so whenever it is jose altuve
comes back whether he works out by
himself he can't do anything his advice
that he's going to get from dusty is hey
just pretend like you never left that's
what ralph garr told him after three or
four seasons of really struggling to
come back after spending two weeks every
year with the marines in season yeah
that that time with the marine corps
reserve is is something that dusty looks
back on with a lot of pride
and you make a great point brett i mean
he's balancing both
trying to establish his major league
career at that time
two balls into strength account to alex
bregman
you know the connections to dusty baker
and joe madden
uh as we take a look at both of them
on the oldest active manager board
two very notable games in each of their
careers managing head-to-head of course
the 2002 world series
which was dusty's last game as giants
manager
and then dusty's last game as
nationals manager in 2017 when joe
madden's cubs beat them in the division
series
three balls in a strike now the count to
alex bregman
bregman a candidate for our youtube
player of the game tonight three rbis
for him
on a three for three night at the plate
and rowan pours in a strike full count
now
yeah on base all four times hit by a
pitch as well go along with those three
singles so a mike trot like game as far
as on base percentage for alex bregman
got him
and the throw down to second base is not
in time they sent brantley
scored it as a stolen bag for michael
this first of the year as the astros put
the play on there
and it looks like everybody's coming off
the field did they call michael out
take a look at what happened here
[Music]
i i didn't see i didn't see brantley
end his contact with the bag
i'm not entirely sure what happened
right there the players are off the
field
and we'll try to sort things out they
must they scored that to strike him out
throw him out double play
what in a wide wide world of sports is
it going on here
[Music]
when you show up to empty stance last
year was not the same
part of my rehab and my motivation to
really get back to this team was being
able to hear those fans and be able to
experience minutemaid pack to the roof
one more time
the noise the atmosphere it's unmatched
we come every day and they support us
they're out there screaming it just
makes us want to play better as a team
i think we have the best fans in
baseball the main reason why we play
because of them
this is one of the most community minded
teams that i've ever been on
and
these guys are very aware that they are
part of the community uh i i had a long
conversation with a lot of the guys that
donated water
um and had a real long conversation with
you know with bregma that always steps
up you know you got out two bay and you
got korea and all these guys always step
up for the community you know i thought
that was pretty
you know pretty cool
so apparently that was scored as a
strike amount throw mount double play
we're gonna show you some replays to
figure out what was going on there jared
walsh is the first to bet for the angels
in the eighth great catch by miles straw
[Applause]
tell you what miles straw out in center
field
had some issues out there in colorado
but here we go back that
strikeout and throw down to second base
brantley was safe but the home plate
umpire ron culpa was all over it as alex
bregman leaned out over home plate and
got right in the way of kurt suzuki
and that was the interference call right
there to get the double play to end the
game
i mean in the inning sorry
you don't have to have contact with the
batter as a catcher
all it has to be is it peed to throw to
second base and that was called
sometimes they could put you back in
first base but on that one call them out
at second
we need to re-wreck the videotape to
sort that out
and we're gonna go back to a commercial
or something like a commercial with one
out here in the eighth we'll be right
back
welcome to angels baseball
tonight join david fletcher as he guides
you through this relaxing baseball
meditation
be sure you are in a comfortable
position
take a deep
breath and now
david
fletcher
angels baseball
mike trout home run
[Music]
helmet nachos
andrew heaney strikeout
the rally monkey
albert pujol's milestone
the big a
anthony rendon defensive highlight
lighting up the halo
david fletcher
david fletcher
this has been
an angel's baseball
meditation
don't miss a minute of exciting angels
action head to the angels youtube page
to catch big moments interviews from
players and alumni and more visit
slash
youtube.com
and subscribe to the channel today
that dude the throwback jersey looked
like fred lin
there's justin upton
the first to face the new pitcher
right-hander joe smith on from the
astros bullpen trying to protect a
six-run lead with one away and the base
is empty in the eighth
joe smith could use a clean outing right
here it's been rough last three and
two-thirds innings he's given up eight
earned runs
that three-quarter arm delivery from the
veteran
gives you a fastball about 86
miles an hour with some sink in
underneath the hands of right-handed
hitters and then a slider that sweeps
across
two balls in a strike to upton who's
over two of the walk tonight
seen a lot of funky arm angles tonight
gooby starting with alex claudio out of
the bullpen ben rowan
and now joe
smith everyone's taking a page out of
what's been successful for the tampa bay
rays different arm angles out of your
bullpen different looks makes it more
difficult for hitters to time it as they
go longer in the game
2-2 to upton there's a shot into left to
base hit
i'm not sure if those boos are from the
uh the two run shot off the foul pole
the other way or the shot off lidge in
o5
could be a combo deal
he literally gets booed every at-bat
he's here at mid-may park every about
i've seen now 10 years with the angels
he's get booed every single time
a ball of no strikes to pujols
continuing his ascent brett up the
all-time leaderboards
well he certainly is
665 home runs but i want to take you
back matt to a couple of years ago
september 2019 right before an angel's
astros game mark langston had a health
scare in the angels radio booth had to
be taken to the hospital of course his
family wasn't with him so after the game
some angels personnel showed up and
langston looked up from his hotel room
pujols came in wanted to pray with him
pray for him langston told me this week
it was just what he needed at that time
we know the impact he's had on the field
the great ones always have an impact as
well off the field don't they
it's a great story three balls and a
strike happy to report that mark
langston is
fit and doing great these days
well i remember going to the hospital
that night when we walked in there after
the game and saw albert in there we were
just
shocked and we had a huge smile on our
face to see that albert made that effort
to go all the way to the hospital to see
mark langston
full council pool holes now three and
two so so much of his largest
and his humanitarian work has gone
uh below the radar
if not
completely unreported
and that that human touch just a small
small example of why albert is so
beloved
full count to him 3-2
smith strikes him out on a pass that
albert would love to have back
[Applause]
point joe smith
played a number of years successful
years with the angels really really good
friends with albert pauls and mike trout
always said the long conversation goes
to visit each other when they're in town
but albert's not going to want to visit
him after that fastball there down and
in because if he made contact that was
going to be off his back leg
here's iglesias that's going to be a
problem for the astros and jose is going
to leg that out as an infield single
that's so good does it feel great about
it but uh yeah there's a relationship
there as well
and now it's roja rojas jose's had a
nice night tonight
led miss diaz is out in short right in
the beer league rover position
baldwin no strikes to count to rojas
boy the average exit velocity for a
major league hit is about what 88.3
miles per hour
i'm guessing there's 20 hits today
there's got to be about 17 of them well
below that
yeah the radar gun is gonna be intact by
the end of this game it will be fine
there have only been one two three four
five six balls hit over 98 miles an hour
that last hit by uh there have been a
major iglesias was a 60 mile an hour
12-foot rocket
up the third baseline
joe madden has said as recently as this
spring training that what we can't
explain
with math
we mistakenly attribute to luck
[Applause]
joe smith in and out of trouble in the
eighth
to the bottom of the inning all astros
in houston tonight
hi i'm robin and i'm a local houston
artist and we're here at minutemaid park
paint and mural in centerfield
hi my name is ethan brannan i'm rite
hickman my name is naib and i'm a
student from the art institute of
houston
and i'm here at minne mae park working
on a mural project
this is honestly an amazing opportunity
for me
i get to work with people that do
graphic design or people do murals and
painting and now i'm kind of getting an
idea of how to have an idea
and put it in physical form
the concept is orbit
sliding into home plate basically just
saying welcome home
welcome back to the stadium welcome back
fans welcome back players just to really
unify everyone
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the mlb game of the week
live on youtube presented by chime with
mark gubzod angel stadium jeff bloom and
brett dolan at minuteman park matt
baskersian
and the astros after the strong start by
christian javier a couple of three run
innings
have never been challenged tonight in
fact we have the finalists for our
player of the game vote alex bregman
carlos correa or christian javier
you can vote now voting remains open
until the final out of the game will
announce the player of the game
on our post game coverage tonight
right after play-by-play
you're done alvarez has single choices
who do you got gooby
uh i'll go with javier he was so good he
set the tone for him tonight if it
wasn't him i would still go with my
writing vote of dusty baker but i'm
going to stay with javier with the way
he threw the night okay
fair enough
blummer do you want to try to influence
the voting who do you got
i wish i could i'm obviously a hitter in
my past but i loved what javier did
going out there getting a career high in
strikeouts with nine and i agree with
gooby he set the tone early because it
was a rough road trip and they needed to
snap that
funk they were in and he brought it
tonight
one ball and one strike to count to
jordan alvarez
high fly ball into center
and there's one gone
there's julie guriel
you know i started uh down this road
earlier and i think game action
prevented me from finishing the thought
but we just saw that shot of carlos
correa
enjoying a
natural potassium break
in the dugout
and
he's he's rocking the sleeve roll up
thing the cut off kind of
if we can see it there he's like rolling
up the bottom of the sleeve and he's
cuffing it
right a little bit of the gun show going
on
appropriate playing the angels kind of
tipping your cap unwittingly to the
great brian downing
who
mastered
the off sleeve
to show off the guns nobody did it
better
superman
was that his real nickname
yeah well as strong as he was yeah he
was uh he wasn't he stood right on the
plate dared you to try to get him out
inside and uh
it's all pitchers remember if you're
into someone hitter's book i'm in his
book too brian downey got me one time so
uh
yeah i remember that well
brian downing was jacked before guys
were jacked
those are some good ball clubs you're
talking about and i grew up in southern
california watching a lot of those
california angel teams
brian downing actually came out and
threw the first pitch at our little
league
when i was a kid oh that's cool
walsh making the catch on that fly ball
to god
well you remember that one highlight
play out in left center field with a
spread lin and bryant downing going for
the ball going towards the wall in that
lucky the fred lin was able to avoid
major contact with downing that would
have been a real big issue for fred
going forward
that was a violent collision out there
there's kyle tucker now with two gone
yeah there's that there's that famous
catch freddie lynn made uh during his
rookie of the year run in 75 where he
collided with the outfield fence at
fenway i think he would have come out in
worse shape had he collided with brian
downing than with an actual fence
the ball into strike to count to tucker
ryan presley up in the bullpen
unscored upon to start the year
little excuse me check swing he went
around on the appeal the ball on two
strikes
certainly not a save situation here for
the astros but presley hasn't been in a
game since saturday
and an opportunity for dusty to get him
some work at the start of this series
three more between these two teams here
in houston
zach grenke and andrew heaney tomorrow
jayco touristy griffin canning on
saturday
and then lance mccullers astros fans
hope
will take the ball sunday to wrap things
up against dylan bundy for the angels
2-2 pitch is sliced in the air long run
and a great sliding catch by jose no
that's is that iglesias no that's rojas
who came out of the shift a fine play
that
believe it or not
is just the second one two three inning
of the game on this side of the
scorecard
last chance for the angels as we go to
the ninth
[Music]
i'm robin sanders and i'm here at
minutemaid park in front of the recently
completed fan appreciation mural in
centerfield
we were busting our tails to get it
finished
day in day out and then to finally get
to the the end process where the
unveiling it was kind of surreal and
just
being there um not just a bystander but
a participant of the
of the unveil with
with media the executives the unveiling
just capped off
what was a great great project
now that the mural is done i'm just
really happy that i got to partner with
the astros on the mural as well as the
three art institute students they were
absolutely incredible
um
so
to the top of the ninth inning last
chance for the angels tonight down by
six
hey coming up on the mlb game of the
week live on youtube
next up twins and indians a day game
from cleveland got the braves and nats
on the schedule good battle from the nl
central in milwaukee
giants of reds
who seem to have played each other a lot
already this year in action as we speak
or just finishing a series the phillies
and marlins coming up at the end of may
another afternoon affair thursday may
27th
three exclusive games only on youtube
all year long
it is ryan presley on to put the
finishing touches on what the astros are
hoping is a series opening win against a
division rival and on the first pitch to
kurt suzuki
presley gets a ground ball out
[Applause]
last time out for ryan presley up in
seattle he picked up his first save of
the year
like matt said has yet to give up an
earned run
pitching in six innings this season he
is another guy with that high spin
fastball but he has two wipeout
secondary pitches with a power slider
and a power curve ball
one out base is empty now for david
fletcher who got his first base hit of
the game in his most recent at-bat
the angel's hopeful that mike trout will
be okay to play tomorrow but that's
certainly something that people will be
watching closely overnight and tomorrow
morning
i know that the angels beat writers are
certainly looking for information
another knock for fletcher
a knuckle ball sent out to right field
it did a right again
for pledge
[Applause]
i think of beauty wow
yeah it was almost like a caitlyn jansen
cut fastball we saw the other day
closing down the game that had some cut
action going the other way
fifth plate appearance tonight for
shohei otani who has been quiet this
evening
0 for four so far
in a more comfortable at-bat against a
right-handed pitcher where his ops
is 200 points higher
over 900 versus right-handed pitching
just over 700 against southpaws
and did not swing the bat
a couple other games going on right now
guys and that big series between the
dodgers and padres has resumed first of
four between those two rivals
and san diego has a two-nothing lead at
dodger stadium in the bottom of the
sixth inning rookie ryan weathers
throwing the ball very effectively for
san diego tonight
boy they've been some great games so far
almost playoff atmosphere already
yeah no love lost between those two
teams this year that each of the three
games in san diego last weekend was
chippy
3-0 fastball's in for a strike
yeah those games against l or for la
against san diego are very enjoyable to
watch i'm still amazed at how good
dodger pitching is
some of the guys that they have on their
starting rotation absolutely amaze me
and i'm not sure how guys get hits off
them
yeah that depth is going to allow them
to do exactly what
they've stated their their goal is and
they're going to start to borrow the nba
term they're going to start the load
management phase of the season in june
where they'll go to a six-man rotation
on occasion they'll pull a guy out
they'll bring somebody up from the
alternate training site and ohtani
strikes out man
he was in front of the count
three-and-oh and then took two big cuts
at upper 90s gas it came up empty
[Music]
and he likes that high fastball it's a
left-handed batter too but he couldn't
catch up to this one there from presley
going fastball upstairs at 96.
for semer
gets it by him
chance for the angels is scott shepler
he has struck out and grounded out since
coming onto the ball game and replacing
mike trout who again earlier was hit by
a pitch in the elbow
the ball that merced mercifully hit him
in the pad but still mike was removed as
a precaution with a elbow contusion
tonight
[Applause]
houston a strike away from a series
opening victory at home
[Applause]
maybe it's the home cooking plumber
they win six of seven to open the season
ran rough shot over the oakland a's
since that series
fortunes of both teams have changed a
little bit and the astros are hopeful
that they're back on track tonight
yeah it's got to feel good to get back
home in front of their home fans hear
the cheering
and to put up a big number here at home
they haven't done that yet yet this year
that'll do it with an exclamation point
and a 95 mile an hour fastball
ryan presley remains perfect to start
the year
and the astros post an 8-2 victory at
home
congratulations to dusty baker we talked
about how he was
on the doorstep of the 1900 club
he enters access tonight
14th on the all-time wins list with his
1900th
managerial win tonight
[Music]
eight to two the final
the mlb youtube game of the week post
game show presented by chime starts
right now
the astros with an 8-2 victory tonight
they take the series opener some tightly
offensive performances multiple hit
nights for guys like carlos correa alex
bregman name brands cashing in tonight
and christian javier with an outstanding
night on the mound the lone angels
highlight was the home run by albert
pujols
one that just scraped the fair pole in
right field his first opposite field
homer in the better part of two years
and the limited capacity crowd that came
to watch this series opener tonight for
the most part is exiting the building
happy after an eight to two win for the
home side
we are awaiting a conversation with our
chime player of the game tonight
a little drama to reveal who that is you
had a vote in this watching at home and
between carlos correa alex bregman
and christian javier we will reveal the
winner of our player of the game honors
and have a conversation with that astro
coming up shortly
i think we've got the winner in place
he is christian javier a career
strikeout high a career pitch count high
and a dominant night on the mound in his
first start in two weeks gooby
yeah i thought his stuff was off the
charts he had the fourth team fastball
going but his slider was a difference
maker going into the game i think his
key would be able to finish off with his
slider well he certainly did that with
nine strikeouts and five innings dusty
baker said before the game they were
gonna hope to stretch him out a little
bit as far as pitch count and he was
right on the money on how well he threw
tonight
christian javier is our player of the
game
taking down the vote by 45 to 33
margin over alex bregman man it is way
too early jeff blum to jump to any
conclusions about
who's truly hot truce huli who's truly
not uh you know not until the 40-game
mark do a lot of us think you can really
get a
sense for what you have on the field but
based on the start the astros had
winning six out of seven based on how
good they look tonight
we expect them to be in the fight all
year long
no and they should be and they have the
pedigree to do it you've seen it in the
past we talked about it in the open how
they've been to the postseason they've
been to it four alcs's so these guys
understand how the season works they
understand that it is going to be a
little bit longer season this year so i
think you're going to see less panic out
of these guys but also when you start
out in a season in april you want to put
good numbers up you want to get off to a
great start they had that for a week
when they went through the oakland a's
all of a sudden they faltered a little
bit when aj hinch and the detroit tigers
came through got beat up a little bit
kind of took it on the chin and then
they had a couple of guys go on the
injured list and i think they started to
reel a little bit and realize that they
might be in a little bit of a tough spot
but these guys have rebounded out
they're waiting to get al touve back
they're waiting to get guys like from
valdez back so things can trend in the
right direction but considering the way
things have been for the last 10 days
this was a very welcome home for them
you know and for the angels on the other
side of this thing mark gubazo you go a
long way to beating the angels when you
keep shohei otani and mike trout quiet
and that's exactly what what christian
javier and company did tonight
yeah when you look at the power threats
you got ohtani trout and jared walsh for
the most part javier and the bullpen for
the astros did a great job as far as
neutralizing that especially with the
breakable throughout the entire game
david fletcher wasn't able to get on
base early in the game as much as we're
used to seeing for the angels so i mean
when you look at this division right now
guys this is a very competitive division
a lot of people are saying well there's
going to be a weaker division coming in
but the oakland a's have been great
seattle's been really good texas has
played pretty solid baseball the angels
have and now the astros you know at some
point will start to play really good
baseball this is going to be a fantastic
race all the way to the end when you go
back and kind of scrutinize the start of
alex cobb tonight you know he was he was
close and again like javier who actually
pitched at the alternate training site
uh it had been a while for alex cobb
since he was last on a big league mound
ten days a long layoff had to start
skipped um
i think he was good and i think the
difference for him tonight
i sound like a guy bellyaching here but
the 1-1 pitch to martine maldonado he
got two out in the third one one pitch
to maldonado was called a ball that was
not it was a strike that at-bat turned
into a double the floodgate opened it
turned into a three-run inning and cobb
was out of the ball game before the end
of the third it's it's a matter of how
one call one pitch can kind of betray
your night i felt like he was on the
verge of pitching out of it a couple
times tonight but couldn't get out of
that final jam
yeah you're exactly right on that every
once in a while you need a pitch or
something to go your way to be able to
go out there and put up the numbers you
expect but i still go back to what we
talked about the very beginning when
you're a sinker ball pitcher and you're
too strong you're going to overthrow
some pitches i didn't think his splitter
was as good as it has been his knuckle
curve was really really good but his
fastball had more lateral movements than
a sinking movement i think that's where
he ran into some problems not a lot of
ground ball action for him i just hit
kim down to it i would be curious to see
what he said after the game that he was
too strong and maybe overthrew some
pitches you know we have our player of
the game standing by with us with the
help of a translator and congratulations
to christian javier a terrific night
tonight christian thanks for joining us
tell us how you felt tonight and what
you felt was working the best for you
this evening
[Music]
all thanks to god for all the success
tonight
i felt good i threw quality strikes over
the plate uh and i felt comfortable
tonight and uh successes to god thank
you
how was it you know when you go into a
game you're preparing for a team that
has showie ohtani mike trout and albert
pools in a lineup how are you able to
stay so focused and be able to throw all
your pitches into strike zone like you
said
trout
for me it was just about staying focused
uh getting the first pitch over the zone
for a strike if i can command the zone
early in account and get ahead then the
rest of that bat was in my favor
el raptil great game today tell me what
it felt like to watch the astros offense
go out there and put up runs while you
were pitching so good
no elegible nosotros
super happy with the hitters
it's a
it's a lot less pressure when the
offense comes through i feel a little
bit more relaxed and can
attack the zone a little bit more well
uh please relate to christian that it
was a pleasure watching him pitch by the
way sir translator thank you for your
help today what is your name i i feel
like we should we should know your name
as well
my name is derek vigoa derek way to go
thanks for helping us out
yeah thank you thank you thank you for
the translation and
congratulations that was great awesome
all right good we've got a player of the
game there's a bull tonight 98 pitches
nine punch outs both of those numbers
are career highs all nine of them
swinging
we're gonna take a break and we'll have
more post-game coverage
when we come back right after this
he
just smokes it
[Music]
[Applause]
strike three that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
something like this is what they came
for
[Applause]
welcome back to our game of the week
post game coverage powered by presented
by
chime an 8-2 win for the astros taking
game one of this four-game set with
division rival
the los angeles angels and if you missed
any of the play-by-play coverage here's
how it went down
yeah blummer javier was down at the
alternate site this is his first big
league start in a couple of weeks but
that was all by design we understand
david fletcher showed ohtani and mike
trout for the visiting angels
strikeout for javier
two strikeouts start the game for
christian javier
pretty nasty change up i'm actually kind
of curious to see this matchup between
christian javier who has that good
fastball in the upper portion of the
zone
jared walsh has the reputation of being
very good on hitting the fastball and
driving it gets a lot of swings
underneath just like that
three strikeouts nothing comes with the
two odd walk underway in houston tonight
christian javier mix in a ground out
dude
all six
via the swinging strikeout and here's
miles straw now
sharply hit past the third baseman rojas
into the corner that's gonna get diaz
around to score
miles straw driving in the first run of
the night and it's one nothing astros
a ball into the short left field corner
then he turns into a triple two balls
and two strikes to correa
and a ground ball that trickles through
the infield and allows straw to score
easily boy that's a two-strike count
that
just got away from cobb
big plate appearance here for julie
gurio
faces loaded here's the 3-2 pitch
and he just missed with the split change
man didn't miss by much
an rbi for guriel is team leading nine
three nothing astros
kyle tucker a strikeout victim to end
the first
and that's lined into cello right where
fletcher had him played perfectly
to avoid any further damage
last year oh man he got hit in the elbow
and i don't know that that got him
there's no pad there i don't think
he has a little protection there right
around the tricep barry but that looks
like you got it right in the elbow
with a slider dude oh really yeah i
can't pick up the ball here though
this stuff looks like that too
mike trout has come out of the ball game
after being hit in the elbow a couple of
innings ago trying to stick around scott
shebler has taken over in center field
for him here's alex bregman now he's
been on base at all three of his plate
appearances tonight two singles and he
was hit by a pitch in the second
add another base hit man he and correa
are going nuts at the top of this order
carlos is going to score
and the astros are on the board again
pulls to right field that's got a chance
if it stays fair and that one's gone
albert pujols to the opposite field to
get the angels on the board in the sixth
wait a minute wait a minute all boundary
calls are reviewable yeah it's gonna
stand you knew it
and that is where the final score would
end nine two or eight two rather astros
so ryan wrestler came on dominant to the
ninth man he is not allowed to run this
year
and looks to be in uh 2018-ish
form so here's the final numbers and
eight to eight to two victory for the
astros they runs on 13 hits two runs on
eight hits for the angels a big note for
the angels is that mike trout left the
game of the fourth after being hitting
the elbow as you saw
the word out of the angels clubhouse was
an elbow contusion good news that there
was nothing further and uh his status of
course will be evaluated for the rest of
the series hey you know as we welcome
you back in uh matt basker's with mark
good jeff blum we talked about some of
the exit velos here guys
you know not everything was hit on the
screws scooby as it were
no i mean you're putting the ball in
play i mean
not a lot of strikeouts for them
contact sometimes soft contact no real
baseballs hit over that hundred mile an
hour mark we're so used to a major
league baseball but to their credit to
both these teams use the high contact
team they scored eight runs today that's
the most since april fourth so it's
pretty impressive to see what they did
with carlos correa at the top fielder
dusty baker decided to make that
decision to put him at the top first
time in his career and it paid off with
a lot of help at that top of the order
and balance throughout the entire lineup
yeah blummer they might have a hard time
getting correa out of that lead off spot
he seemed to like it uh the final
results seem to like it maybe that's
your new lead off hitter until altuve is
back in the mix
yeah they definitely needed a shake up
and dusty baker wanting to go out there
and get that get that 1900th win he went
out and got it today by having carlos
curry at the top and you talk about
really like shaking things up i don't
think correa was one of those guys they
anticipated because in the past he's
been a four five six hole type hitter
where he gets the opportunity to drive
in runs has a high risk number drives
the ball out of the ballpark has some
key moments but we talked about it
earlier in the game you want guys at the
top of your lineup to get the most at
bats and carlos correa is one of those
guys that has been swinging the bat very
well he's got a keen eye and he also has
an opportunity to put your team up early
with the power that he has very similar
to george springer who left to go to
toronto one of those things that dusty
baker was wondering about with us before
the game who's going to lead off we got
correa in there you know dickie thon not
available uh cesar cedeno not available
pichio's in the front office now they
found him uh brett and that lineup
construction worked out really well
tonight for the astros
boy it certainly did and even though
christian javier was our player of the
game we started this telecast talking
about how the houston astros needed to
win they needed some offense and they
got both today in their previous four
games they had eight runs they got eight
runs tonight on 13 base hits two-thirds
of the lineup was on base at least
multiple times combination of hits or
hits and walks alex bregman had the
three base hits that certainly was a
bright side as well and this is still a
team waiting to get jose altuve back
healthy they hope productive jordan
alvarez has not played much at all over
the last couple of years so there's
another guy they hope to be able to
build towards over the next couple of
months and you guys talked about it
oakland's won 11 straight they may come
back to earth what's the staying power
for the seattle mariners the angels
obviously would like to get rendon back
astros would like to get altuve back so
this could be a wild american league
west race the rest of the year you know
lance berkman was a guy who played a lot
of games on this field behind me and
blummer probably knows this lance was
always fond of saying a hitter is only
as confident as his last game or his
last couple of at-bats so at least for
tonight this astros team probably goes
home feeling pretty good about
themselves for the first time in
probably about a week well said brett
great stuff uh you bet let's take
another break and eight to two win for
the astros and we're back with more on
our post game coverage presented by
chime coming up next
he has been the mvp of our season
continues to be most underrated player
on our roster
runner goes and it's a ball throw down
to third out of third base
what he's been able to do and how he's
been able to help our young pitching
staff through the season he's just the
uh you know the rock of his team and his
his will to win the grit that he has is
something that i admire a lot otto will
drive this to deep left center field
home run
[Music]
big moment for the astros and kyle
tucker kyle tucker pitch on the way
and tucker hits it high in the air to
right field that sends back
looking up see you later see you later
kyle tucker with a walk-off home
run and the astros beat the mariners 3-2
thank you
to
welcome back to the mlb game of the week
live on youtube our post game coverage
is presented by chime eight to two
astros in this series opener tonight
three more to come against these two
teams
starting tomorrow and the hope for
angels fans is that mike trout after
being hit by the
hit by a pitch in the elbow tonight is
okay to continue mike wore a mic for us
and here is mike on the mic
no dude i honestly thought it was a
slider buddy
i didn't see it that's what i thought he
is yeah
i see you talking about the new map
yeah yeah i've haven't played tonight
[Applause]
yeah
i thought it was a slider dude oh really
dude i can't pick up the ball here
though you know what i mean so i like i
kind of like was waiting for it to break
and
dude if i didn't i don't think if i had
my pad there if i have a pad bro
yeah mike trout would come out of the
game shortly thereafter we talked about
this a little bit during play-by-play
goofy the fact that he hits only 218
here you know those are not mike trout
numbers in any ballpark so lowest of any
major league stadium right here in
houston
yeah i mean every other ballpark
especially any other ballpark in the al
west he has incredible numbers but
they're at minutemate park he's really
had a tough time seeing the baseball and
by the way i just saw that joe madden
said he expects mike trout to be in the
lineup tomorrow so that's good news for
the angels fans of any baseball fantasy
trout back in the lineup but this
doesn't see the ball real well he wasn't
able to determine if it was a slider or
even a fastball today for christian
javier when he hit him in the elbow so
hopefully mike trout will be back up
there and get a little bit better swings
and see the ball a little bit better
down there in houston
yeah are you talking about first of all
i agree yeah go ahead
oh sorry to jump in man first of all i
agree everybody wants to see mike trout
out there swinging the bat and putting
up big numbers but here at minute maid
park it's kind of interesting to have
him miked up and be as open as he was
talking about his inability to see the
ball here at minute maid park we talked
about the batter's eye being a little
bit different the led lighting and i've
had several conversations with jeff
bagwell talking about the days back at
the astrodome where guys would come in
and have to adjust to the lighting in
those ballparks so it's kind of unique
that this is one of those ballparks that
gives them trouble and maybe it's the
maybe it's the 10th man for the houston
astros when mike trout comes to town
because that seems to be the only
kryptonite this guy has
yeah watch what'll happen he gets
drilled in the elbow today he's going to
come out there tomorrow hit three
dingers and you know so well so much for
i can't see the ball at minutemate park
we've seen that movie before you know
what else we saw tonight uh yeah it's
limited fan participation but our fan of
the night
third inning
slicing foul ball
check this dude out epic fall
ah
oh
and he lived to tell about it
he was all smiles afterwards thanks for
being a good sport sir
hey elsewhere on the
on the falling fail docket
monday in philadelphia
brandon belt gets a hold of one and it
rattles around and look at this hey
oh
good lord
like he was wearing skates ice skates
like three-time stanley cup champion
ken danako right here in new jersey oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
how if kenny is uh happy with us for
that but uh you know
it's oh that's mr devin i
i know he can mix it up a little bit so
glad we're uh pretty far away from him
as we laugh at that
managed my goodness for social
distancing yeah yes yes yes
and thank goodness for social media
because now those clips will live
forever uh before we go we want to
remind fans of the rest of this package
the mlb game of the week live on youtube
these are exclusive games that you can't
see anywhere else
and the next one is coming at you
wednesday the 28th
six days from today day game between the
twins and indians at progressive field
got the braves nationals cardinals
brewers giants and reds
and the phillies and marlins then coming
up
thursday may 27th
hey the twins and indians is an
interesting matchup guys because there
were a lot of people that felt like it
was the twins in white sox division to
lose cleveland is without
carlos carrasco without francisco lindor
but it's a pitching factory there and
any staff that still got shane bieber on
it for me has a puncher's chance i think
they think that they're every bit the
competitor in that division along with
the white sox and twins gooby
yeah they got some great pitching and
when you look at how many home runs they
fit they don't have a you know a really
deep lineup but they've hit a lot of
long balls they scored some runs that
way but their pitching staff a young
pitching staff is so good but byron
buxton by the way for the twins one of
the best players in the game it's going
to see him back out there he was not
available in the angel series but i'll
tell you what he does incredible stuff
out in the outfield great throwing arm
power and speed elite speed we talked
about ohtani buxton has that elite speed
as well
yeah i couldn't agree more they've got
byron buxton who was a second pick
behind carlos correa who's really coming
to his own he was a swinging miss guy
early but it's been great to watch him
make the adjustment and start to drive
the ball out of the ballpark always been
a gold glove centerfielder for me from
the time he stepped on the field so it's
going to be a lot of fun to watch that
division match up a little bit great
pitching for cleveland and of course the
ageless wonder nelson cruz out there
dropping bombs still
yeah it's minnesota twins looking up at
the rest of the division oddly off to a
wonky 6-10 start kansas city the team to
beat right now in the al central setting
the pace with a 10-7 record guys this
was a lot of fun tonight uh thanks for
doing this and uh i had a blast working
with you guys been a long time that
we've all known each other and we
finally got to do a game together
tonight so it was fun thanks a lot
thanks matt blummer you guys are great
man it was a blast hanging with you guys
and i finally got on the field for the
first time in two years down here at the
field you want to do some running and
show it off for us i mean you could rip
off the headset and run the bases no
no
no
no they won't let me do that right now
because i have to show off my athletic
skills
no thanks for having me on guys fella it
was great seeing you guys i miss all of
you can't wait to see you in person and
thank you for breaking me in gently and
thanks to brett dolan as well for his
contributions tonight uh good times
everybody it's a wrap
the astros take game one of the series
by final score of eight to two the next
mlb game of the week live on youtube
presented by chime wednesday april 28th
the twins and indians from cleveland
ford mark good jeff plum
and brett dolan matt bastrossian saying
so long thanks for watching
[Applause]
um
um
[Music]
you